This is Jocko podcast number 19 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay.
I want you to think about something
and I want you to remember it in that is that these books that I review and go
through,
they're written by people,
real people.
They're not movies.
And when you picture what's happening in the book,
don't picture it as a movie
cause we get inundated with so much.
Yeah.
Imagery.
Okay.
That we actually think the world is movies and television.
But these books,
they're not
movies.
They're not television,
they're real.
And these things really happened.
They didn't happen on a screen or just in someone's mind and they weren't played
by some actor.
And when I talk about that fear that a soldier and Grazi was feeling,
it's not part of some script.
Okay.
Isn't just a book.
It's real.
That's a real person.
A person.
Yeah.
Who really had those thoughts and those fears.
And when I rattle off the figure of 800,000 Tutsis killed by the Hutus in the
Rwandan genocide,
that's not just a number.
Those weren't,
yeah.
Extras in a movie.
They were people,
people like you.
And people like me,
people with families and friends and hopes and dreams and jobs and lives
people
and so remember that now
as we join [inaudible].
Okay.
United States Marine Corps recruit.
Yeah.
Chuck Tatum,
November,
1943 at the Marine Corps recruit depot in San Diego,
California.
That bayonet training was a new experience.
None of us would forget.
It was tough,
rugged,
and required perfect physical conditioning.
After we read the bayonet chapter in our guidebook,
corporal leary marched us to the training range along the shore of San Diego Bay
to learn this lethal art of war.
I remember one paragraph in the bay in that chapter that got my attention.
The rifle and bayonet in the hands of a marine become a deadly combination of
Spear Sword,
club and shield at night.
This combination weapon could kill silently and with surprise in hand to hand
fighting when the rifle cannot be reloaded and the use of grenades would be
impractical,
impractical.
It is the decisive weapon
at these times.
The aggressive bayonet fighter will win.
Leary quietly explained an assault is the critical moment of any combat and a
bay and Neto salt executed by determine marines can turn the tide.
Men eager to engage an enemy with cold steel will strike terror in their ranks.
He emphasized four points.
One,
get the blade into the enemy.
It's the blade that kills
to be ruthless,
vicious and fast,
and your attack never paused and your attack until you have one.
There is only one winner and a band at fight.
Make sure it's you
seek vital areas,
but don't wait for an opening.
Make one the best killing zones are the throat and the belly are solid rifle
butts.
Stroke in the groin will open your enemies guard,
deliver it hard,
and then go for the kill
for protect yourself.
Your rifle and bayonet.
Make a good shield.
Use their protection by dodging and parrying.
But remember the best defense is to attack first,
strike the first blow and follow through.
So they're trained in these young marines,
obviously since 1943 they're getting ready to go and fight.
They know for a fact they're getting ready to go and fight.
And you can see the psychological aspect of bayonet training and you know it is
an absolute,
yeah,
sure you might get in a band that fight.
But this is a psychological training to get them aggressive,
to get them in the mindset of striking first to get them in the mindset of
killing.
Hmm.
Cause that's what they're getting ready to go do.
And as they continued to train,
this episode took place.
Now there,
there are a little bit further along and training and here we go.
During a marching break,
one hot afternoon,
a marine remarked screw all the training.
I'm sick and tired of all this pussy footing around.
I want to get overseas and slap me at Jap.
This remark was made in the presence of Sergeant George Lucas,
who immediately caught them off saying,
hold on,
sunny,
let me tell all of you a thing or two about the Japanese soldier.
Number one,
he's not the caricature you see in the newspapers with bombs,
sight glasses and buck teeth.
The average Japanese soldier has five or more years of combat experience.
Their army doesn't have a boot.
Does division like ours?
Don't forget the jabs of already conquered half of the nations in Asia.
Remember Pearl Harbor,
not only are they better trained than you are right now.
Many are old hands at combat fighting and have a strict military code.
They live and die by called Bushido.
Literally translated.
It means way of the warrior with their code combined with their pledge to die
for the emperor who they consider God.
They will die before surrendering.
JAP soldiers are well equipped and are experts with their weapons.
They are trained to endure hardships which would have most of you guys writing
your congressmen.
I don't like jabs,
but I respect them as fellow soldiers.
I learned my respect the hard way on Guadalcanal.
Jeff's Japs are the worst.
The world's best snipers experts at the art of camouflage and get by on a diet
of fish heads and rice.
They will never surrender and we'll commit Harry Carey rather than being taken
prisoner.
Heck,
they don't even have Korman.
If they are wounded,
they're considered damaged goods.
So Sunny,
mull that over and don't ever let me hear you complain about your training
again.
There'll be a time when your life will depend on what you learned in the days
ahead.
That's,
yeah.
Obviously anyone that's listening that's in the military,
that's in law enforcement.
That's a message you need to get to your younger troopers,
that the training that you're doing your life may very well depend on it at some
point in the,
in the future,
in the near future,
in the far future,
you don't know,
but you got to take advantage of it.
Now we get to win a chuck Tatum is done with bootcamp and he's checking in and
he meets a American hero on my third day at Pendleton.
This is Camp Pendleton.
For those of you that don't know what that is,
it's in southern California.
On my third day at Pendleton,
I was sitting on my bunk when I heard footsteps echoing through the empty
barracks.
I looked up and through the hallway came a cheerful looking marine in dress
greens on his arm where the Chevrons of a platoon sergeant,
a hash mark,
a dormed one sleeve and combat red ribbons decorated his left chest,
the lump.
This is his buddies called the lump.
The lump and I jumped to immediate attention after spotting the sergeant stripes
on his sleeve,
looking straight at us,
a smile crossing his lips.
The new rival said quietly and with authority.
Addys men.
How's everything going on platoon,
platoon sergeant John Baz alone.
Okay.
He was Husky with geneal,
handsome looks and his uniform.
Had a comfortable traveled look.
I noticed strands of jet black curly hair peeking out from under his garrison
cap,
which was set at a cocky angle.
Yeah.
While I responded to his greeting,
it hit me.
I was in the presence of a Marine Corps legend Manila.
John Bows alone was the first marine enlisted man to receive the medal of honor
in World War II for actions on Guadalcanal.
We had heard about him in bootcamp.
Okay.
I never had the courage to ask basil loan directly why he had received the medal
of honor on the canal.
I didn't have to ask.
I already knew.
All American knew his story was required reading in every red blooded household.
Sergeant John Basel loons metal of honor citation,
read while the enemy was hammering at the marines.
Defensive positions.
Sergeant Basil alone in charge of two sections of heavy machine guns,
fought valiantly to check the savage and determine result assault
witnesses who investigated the results of the night action during daylight.
Remarked on the gruesome evidence of wholesale slaughter of Japanese soldiers in
front of Basel owns position.
They counted 38 riddled and mangled enemy bodies and credited to the kills to
the fighting sergeant using a 45 caliber pistol and his faithful machine guns.
This remarkable feat was accomplished during the night when Basil alone was at
the same time changing spent machine gun barrels,
clearing jams and running barefoot for Ammo to keep his sections,
guns spitting death.
And so if you know anything about Basil,
Oh,
and after he did that on Guadalcanal,
he,
they pulled him back to America,
right?
And what they would pull them back to America,
it was,
was basically go around and make speeches.
And all this is documented very well,
uh,
or,
or imitated,
very,
or shown very well in the movie,
the Pacific or the series that Pacific.
So he gets pulled back to America and they make him go out.
And do these war bond speeches and ease.
He's not having a good time.
It's not who he is,
right?
He's,
he's just,
uh,
a guy that wants to get after it.
And so he literally goes to go to his commanders and says,
listen,
I want to go back to fight.
I want to go back to the war.
And by the way,
when he was doing those bond sales,
he was living,
you know,
a complete life of luxuries.
He was meeting movie stars and he was getting treated like a movie star and all
that did nothing for him.
He wanted to go back to the fight.
So he ends up going back.
Now some of the other training,
I had to throw this in there,
one of the other sergeants that was helping train them was a guy named Bissonnet
and among business other towns was it was his ability to instruct us in the art
of Jujitsu Beers taught us how to escape a half Nelson headlock by relaxing,
holding our arms straight and letting our body go limp.
Once out of the hold,
we could reach back and pull the legs out from underneath our attacker.
Then by pulling out a k bar knife biz showed us how to dispatch our assailant.
So what you back then learning a little bit of the Jujitsu.
All I know a lot of people will recognize that that move if you're trained,
and all of this of course was to prepare for this island hopping campaign in the
Pacific.
That's what it was.
And
for Chuck Tatum,
that started on the black sands of [inaudible].
So they hit the beach on the Jima,
you know,
after the workup going overseas,
more training in Hawaii,
they finally get to this point where they hit the beach
and here he is on the beach for the first time.
And here's what chuck Tatum says.
I noticed a loan marine walking back and forth on the shore among hundreds of
preowned figures kicking behinds,
shouting,
crosswords and demanding move out,
get your butts off the beach.
He gave the Marine Corps hand signal for follow me.
A group of men responded,
fascinated.
I wondered why he wasn't digging in like the rest of us as he advanced as he
advanced.
I recognize that the solitary marine was none other than Gunnery Sergeant John
Basilone,
Charlie company's living legend and the Marine Corps icon was headed toward me
and Steve has dungarees were freshly washed and irons his helmet,
his helmet strap was on hooked.
He held a carb carbine in his left hand and he had already ditched his
cumbersome gas mask.
Moslem wore a light field pack and showed no fear as if this invasion was no
more than a serious training maneuver.
I also saw Colonel Lewis Sea,
the 27th marines,
executive officer,
he and Basil Own.
We're the only two men standing up shouting obscenity is in orders.
The forward surge of Basil ohms group carried them to our position.
Only bassline and plain defied the firestorm raging around us.
Move out,
move out,
get the hell off the beach.
You dumb sons of bitches.
They screamed,
kicking us,
running the butts right and left
what I thought was yet another mortar shell falling in the same spot as before.
Exploded 75 feet in front of Steve and me.
The blast shockwave whipped up black dirt that pushed its way into my eyes and
for sand into my mouth,
making me gag.
It was uncomfortable and nasty,
but my worry wasn't for myself.
I hope that dirt,
what wouldn't foul our weapon,
Basil and ran up,
whacked me on the helmet and pointed to the area where I thought the mortar
shells had been regularly hitting only when the sand and dust cleared.
I could see that Basil and was pointing at the aperture of a reinforced concrete
bunker or block house.
The structure probably how's a 75 millimeter or larger cannon who's fueled the
fire,
was directed down the beach to our right.
It was a big bastard with incredible killing power.
It stills,
we're stalling the advance it by killing men of the fourth division.
It may have been firing tree bursts,
which is basically anti-personnel shrapnel that explodes in the sky and rains
down.
Hail on ground troops running 35 feet to the spot picked by basil,
and our field of fire was now diagonal to the aperture of the blockhouse cannon.
We opened fire again and the tracer rounds,
we're right on target now.
I was pleased my bullets forced the enemy gunners to close their gun port with
their arm report closed.
The front of the block house was blind,
even though it was temporarily out of commission.
I still wanted to fire at it,
Basil and signal to me to commence firing again and I directed.
And then he directed a flame thrower,
operator corporate,
William Peg,
a marine of imposing size to repeat their precarious path taken by the demo man
along our line of streaking bullets.
So you've got some cover and move going on.
You've got chuck Tatum laying down fire and now you've got to a flame thrower
operator.
And if you know anything about those flame throwers,
they're carrying big giant.
It looks like scuba tanks on their backs.
They weighed 70 or 80 pounds and obviously these are prime targets,
you know,
for the enemy because the enemy hates these things.
So if you're wearing one of these things on your back,
you're,
you're getting sniper shots at you and everyone's trying to kill you.
Basil and whacked me on the helmet to signal cease firing.
I didn't want to quit.
Everything was working perfectly.
Why stop?
I could see tracer rounds pounding into the building and left and felt extreme
satisfaction with my accomplishment.
Nevertheless,
I ceased firing is ordered and peg peg is the guy carrying the,
the flame thrower staggered under the 70 pound weight of his tanks and
equipment.
Cautiously moved toward the shattered bunkered walls,
sticking his flame thrower nozzle into the smoldering hole.
He ignited his napalm releasing 350 pounds per square inch of pressure in his
tanks.
There was a loud roar of the sound and it looked like a fire spitting dragons.
Jaw erupted the unsuspecting and stun men inside didn't know the horror that was
about to engulf them.
They were cast instantly in the center of a roaring inferno and incinerating
searing hell.
I felt a surge of elation when the flame shot inside.
It wasn't because the gruesome conflagration and agony that we're about to
overwhelm the enemy,
but because of our success,
no one could live through po pegs,
Napalm,
Pyre,
Sergeant Basil,
and had directed this operation by the book exactly the way we'd practice it at
Pendleton and Camp Tarawa.
So it's perfect covered move.
And the reason he sees his fire is because you have to cease fire so that the,
so that the guy with a flameflower can actually get close enough because when
you're shooting at that building,
there's ricochets going all over the place so that he has to cease fire at the
last moment so the guy can get right up close
as I lay prone again,
ready to fire basil and stood astride my back,
startling me bending over.
He grabbed the machine gun bail in one hand with a practice motion,
unlocked the tripod,
releasing the gun.
He screamed in my ear,
get the belt and follow me.
Basil own,
ran toward the roof of the old block house,
grabbed what was left of the cloth ammo belt,
my arms,
and I followed him at a gallop up the slopes of the ruined in placement standing
on top.
We could look down on the rear entrance.
This is the rear entrance of the pill box.
There was a low area,
30 feet in diameter where some of the Japanese defenders had run to escape the
blistering inferno inside Basil and cut them down.
Firing from the hip.
The machine gun vibrated it's powerful arms.
He sprayed the enemy.
Soldiers helped by the basil loan bail,
a wooden handle fascinated by wire to the barrel of the weapon that was inspired
by Basil owns metal of honor engagement on canal.
When he was burned carrying the hot machine gun.
Without the bail,
it would've been nearly impossible to control the blistering machine gun when
it's tripod was taken off.
Mowing down the screaming Japs was purely a mercy slang pitifully.
The men were frantically trying to wipe away the still flaming jelly gasoline
sticking to their tortured bodies.
The putrid smell of burning human flesh nearly made me want to vomit.
Basil loans,
eyes continue to fury I had never seen before.
His jaw was rigid,
clenched hard and sweat.
Glisten done his forehead.
He was not an executioner,
but a true marine performing his duty for me and others who saw Sergeant Basil
owns actions during our assault.
His leadership and courage were overwhelming.
Meanwhile,
Charlie Company,
riflemen and Steve Evanson shot the Japs is they screamed in agony.
Intense.
Oh,
salts.
Yeah,
just completely intense.
And again,
this is a guy that's already won the medal of honor and he's out there taking
charge and leading troops.
He has no B,
had no,
um,
was not required to be there.
He could be back in the states with,
you know,
in Hollywood rubbing elbows with the,
with the,
with the movie stars.
But no,
there,
there he is back in combat.
Back on it.
You Owe Jima and leading.
Okay.
We came under intense fire from a gun,
from gun placements on the slope of Mount Suribachi less than a mile away and
took shelter in a crater made by one of our own 16 inch guns from a or a very
large bomb mortar rounds fired from enemy positions at the north end of the
runway.
Started to fall in our immediate area.
We knew someone was watching us.
On top of everything else,
we began receiving incoming fire from off shore,
US Navy vessels.
These were not misguided rounds.
We had moved so far and fast that this rolling barrage that was intended for the
entrenched Japanese defenders was now hitting us.
So now we were bracketed by Sarah Bace,
by the enemy held high ground to the north and by our own navy.
I always want to bring up these points of of blue on blue and how chaotic it is.
No one realizes that.
How hard it is to deconflict fires in combat.
Yeah.
Back to the book of the three dangers we faced,
I feared our navy the most.
I'd already seen the destructive power that their shells caused when they
pounded the Japs beach defenses.
I firmly believed we'd be killed if we stayed inside our giant shell hole with
what seemed to be an instant common consent.
Everyone in our small groups started to fall back.
Basil alone stopped the retrograde movement in our tracks by ordering.
Dig in and hold this ground.
Come hell or high water.
I'll go back for more men.
Okay.
Manila.
John's perfect.
That was a John Basel.
His nickname was Manila.
John Manila.
John's professional combat expertise had broken up a human log jam on the beach
and wiped out a major Japanese defense position.
Now his moral leadership would hold together a small group of green troops and
advanced position.
Okay.
I gingerly peered from our position toward the landing beach 75 yards away.
A group of Marines was advancing toward the runway with Baz alone in the lead.
Okay,
this is so,
so basil on it.
God back,
get more troops and now they're coming back to their position.
I felt momentary elation,
gunny basil,
and was coming back with more men.
Then I heard enemy rounds falling to earth from the relative safety of our shell
hole.
I watched in horror as the explosions tour.
Basil owns body apart.
It was awful.
It looked like sergeant Baz loan was down.
Okay?
Sometime that afternoon,
the word reached us basil loans,
dead,
America's hero dead.
My own hero killed.
How could he be dead?
Okay?
I couldn't believe it.
The legend of Basil alone alleging born in the jungles of Guata canal,
the hero I had read about and bootcamp who stature had grown larger on the black
and bloody sands of [inaudible].
As I held the machine gun belt for him,
okay?
He was gone.
We will all miss you.
I fought as tears cut paths down.
My grime covered face.
I thought of Basil owns cocky smile,
curly black hair,
and the way he wore his hat at a jaunty angle over one year,
he had a unique personal style and charisma
for me at least.
No one could ever be like Baz alone
America,
the United States Marine Corps and Charlie company.
First Battalion 27th marines had lost a hero dead at 29
okay.
Basil,
lonesome death strengthen our makeshift squad.
Resolve showed on the faces of 17 marines,
told to hold our position,
come hell or high water.
We were receiving fire from all quarters.
The shells were pouring
okay
in on us,
which shrieks and a house and shredding the earth around us.
Enemy gunners on Suribachi now turned their ballistic attentions on us using
observed and directed fire from their lava layer.
Five inch shells from ships mingled in the brew of devastation smashing across
the La landscape.
Sarah bace defenders continued shooting at us while Japanese mortar men north of
the airfield pursued their deadly pounding of the marines along the beach.
The invasion area was a tangle of equipment and supplies,
smashed vehicles and sunken naval craft reserve and support units continue to
pile up and congested mess thousands of men.
The dead,
the wounded,
the terrified and those trying to unload supplies swarmed over the black sand.
Yeah,
we are now targeted by our navy's gun fire.
I wasn't sure of the size and bore of the projectiles or if emanated from a
battleship or destroyer,
but I did know that they chilled my blood as they came shrieking in.
We would be safer if we withdrew to establish lines so that we would be behind
incentive in front of the navy shells.
But sergeant Basilone had ordered us to stay and that alone was sufficient
enough reason to remain.
None of us would disobey his direct order.
We believed it was only a matter of time before others would reach us and we'd
be free to move on.
Brutal.
Okay.
And and by the way,
this is,
this is an example,
this is chuck Tatum's first combat experience.
His first combat experience you use out of boot camp,
did some training in Hawaii,
did some training on Tarawa and then boom,
here he is.
Back to the book.
Turning to my right,
I saw an inspiring sight,
survivors of our Bravo company with sergeant window out in front followed by
Lloyd heard and the ammo carriers were approaching us.
What we were witnessing where the remnants of Baker company,
we were happily reunited with her.
And the other ammo carriers,
but devastated by the news.
Our company,
it's suffered severe losses during the beach of salt.
We had 17 men killed and 51 wounded
couple hours in 17 killed and 51 wounded,
so now we're ease.
Reflecting on what this morning is feeling like.
Our first morning on [inaudible] when we were paying helplessly by mortar
barrages on the black sand beaches,
we were reminded of warnings by veterans who said the Japs are the world's best
soldiers with a knee mortar though chilling those warnings worn,
exaggerated,
even the blunt advice of the vets didn't convey the pure horror of an enemy
mortar attack.
It was pure hell to be caught in the open.
When the Japs opened up with a full mortar attack,
the sound of mortars,
Swish,
swishing through the air froze my blood
against these invisible missiles.
There was no defense.
If we were caught in the open,
all we could do is hit the deck.
A foxhole offered little protection from these high trajectory missiles because
they dropped straight down on us.
Again.
This is a lack of control of your environment.
We've heard this over and over again.
The indirect fire,
the mortars,
the artillery that you can't control and it's random and that's the most
horrifying thing to everybody.
The rear areas,
particularly the eastern or landing beaches where support forces were working,
suffered a bloody pounding,
sunken broach,
landing craft,
piled up along the beaches,
multimillions of dollars worth of valuable equipment and vessels had been
systematically wrecked by deadly accurate Japanese shelling debris washed
ideally back and forth in the frothing surf human wreckage.
The wounded,
dead and dying littered the cold sand.
Yeah,
engineers,
CBS and shore party personnel struggled to create order from chaos.
Doctors and Korman too often fought a losing battle against a grim reach.
Reaper watching over our battlefield,
armed with simple field dressings and infusions of hold blood,
they tried to stem the tide of human suffering and life's blood pouring into
ilos lava hide
are Korman turned into angels of mercy.
They saved hundreds of marines daily and tried to ease the pain of the hopeless
cases with liberal injections of morphine.
Now,
well,
there's obviously a famous picture from you.
Oh,
GM of the marines raising the flag on one on one corner.
And I think raising the flag Max,
it was a coreman raising the flag on it.
You Owe Jima and
this is what it looked like for him.
And this does not mean you get the impression that the fighting was over with,
that the fighting was not over you when you look at the picture.
Yeah.
When you looking at better.
Okay.
We won.
We hadn't,
we weren't even close yet.
Hmm.
But they did take a prominent terrain feature and this is what it was like for
Chuck Tatum as a 26 marines press their attack.
Enemy mortars began falling in our rest area.
Japanese weapons were capable of firing from one end of the island to the other
with thousands of marines crawling around in concentrated areas.
It was an easy task to keep our advancing troops under fire from our reserve
positions near the beach.
It was possible to witness the battle raging for the possession of Mount
Suribachi through sergeant Windells field classes.
We took turns watching the upward progress of our men as they approached the
steep rocky slopes.
It appeared that the 28th marines were at the base of the volcano haze from the
battle obscured my vision,
but we could tell that it was one hell of a fight going on.
Yeah.
It felt sickening to be in reserve watching a battle where men were dying almost
before our eyes.
Yeah.
It kind of seemed like watching a motion picture from the wrong end of a
telescope,
if that makes any sense.
At about 10:00 AM Steve Slap
me on the back and pointed Turd.
Suribachi shouting Tatum.
Do you see that?
I twist it around and saw the stars and stripes clearly on the peak waving in
the breeze,
the 28th marines,
we're now king of [inaudible] was hill
cheers from thousands of marines and roared and reverberated across the island.
I felt a surge of pride.
I was proud to be a marine and proud to be an American fighting on he will,
but we weren't attending a picnic.
Live shells were still dropping on us throughout.
He,
well,
Steve and I soon forgot the flag raising as we Bisley re-engineered our fox
hole,
digging deeper into mother.
He because like it or not,
the word was that the Japanese still occupied more of the woe than the marines
to prove that they were still the main landlord.
The enemy sent a message via concentrated artillery and mortar attack.
Now a couple of days go by and
Chuck Tatum's feet are getting messed up from being in socks and dirt wet and so
he need to get some,
some clean socks and there's basically one place to get them.
Given the condition of my feet,
I knew additional socks were imperative.
I asked sergeant window for permission to make a run to the dead man or casually
pile to look for a pair.
The dead man or casually pile contained clothing,
equipment and weapons of dead or wounded marines.
I had to go a quarter of a mile and as I hobbled there,
I felt uneasy in a bit guilty about the prospect of being a scavenger,
but I had no choice.
The demands and horrors of elbows,
battlefield left,
no other ready solution to the problem of resupply.
I hesitantly picked up a pack only to drop it instantly.
There was a bullet hole straight through it.
Okay.
I found another one intact and solely lifted it.
Trying to see the stenciled name of its previous owner.
Curiosity got the best of me.
It wasn't anyone I knew undoing the straps.
I carefully remove the contents.
There were two perfectly clean and dry pair of green wool socks.
Uh,
so you Lloyd folder lay at the bottom of the pack and it felt the ground.
As I shook out the contents,
I opened the folder.
A photo of a smiling girl beamed at me.
All my love to Joe Maryland
was neatly written across the bottom of the photograph.
I carefully replaced the folder in the pack instead of prayer for Joe and
Maryland.
Yeah,
you're taking gear from dead and wounded marines.
Now they're out continuing to press through.
Okay.
Continuing to make slow progress,
but they are making progress leaving or machine guns.
We spread out in an infantry style formation to comb the area.
Our search for snipers was fruitless,
but we did find a dead enemy soldier in a clump of bushes.
The smell rotting his corpse almost made me puke.
The stench could gag.
A maggot.
Steve said bloated the body was a spider trap
and almost unrecognizable as having been a human being.
His uniform was charred,
so I thought that it might have been,
he might have been hit by a flame thrower.
Bloating had caused the tunic buttons of the cadavers uniform to pop off there.
No,
it was no skin on what had been the face,
but the putrid flesh had scabbed over.
Swarms of flies were attacking the torso and maggots were wiggling in the eyes.
I guess we were lucky you will had no buzzards a rifle lay beside the body.
No one touched it.
They might be booby trap.
Don't screw with it.
Later resting in our reserve area.
I looked at my watch,
saw it was 3:30 PM and decided to eat a k ration.
Seeing the body of dead jabs had become so common place.
I could erase this one from my thoughts.
It had nothing to do with me.
I had become as hardened to death as an undertaker.
Moving on,
pausing to consolidate.
The men were hit with grenades,
mortars and machine gun fire.
From there explode flanks and rear
and this is taking place as there
performing an assault on a hill.
Cleverly,
the Japanese had sprung a trap mortar fire from behind three 62 alpha.
That's the name of the hill.
Caves in front of the cliff opened up and Alva companies.
First platoon was the hardest hit,
incurring heavy casualties at 1:30 PM uh,
Alpha company had to pull back as quickly as the hail of machine gun fire and
bullets would allow
more.
Men were lost trying to save the wounded.
The work that had gone into arming and fortifying hit hill three 62 alpha.
The Japanese version of the Maginot Line in France was awesome and it was
serving its designers purpose.
It was stopping the marines.
The trap sprang shut and we were in it.
Japanese mortars winged in greeting our attack.
We took cover machine guns and rifle fire rep did from every crack and crevice
and hill three 62 alpha.
The mountain was spewing death and destruction from every Fisher and his
volcanic hide.
There was no way to fight back.
We couldn't see our enemy,
but they could see us.
And they had us dead in their sites.
We scrambled over the rocky terrain without cover.
Steve and van carried our machine gun followed by pops with comb and Lloyd heard
our ammo bearers and orchestra of marine and Jap mortars,
machine guns,
rifles and artillery creator roaring,
shrieking,
clamor inducing terror throughout the ranks,
stopping our forward momentum
with mounting casualties at nightfall approaching.
We consolidated our positions and dug in.
We were literally nose to nose with our mortal enemies.
Some of the enemy physicians were less than 40 feet in front of us.
The days fight had cost.
The battalion an estimated 100 casualties for a gain of 200 yards.
A typical days fighting on a UL
going forward.
Continuing to push
back to the book mortar machine gun and targeted rifle fire torn to the company.
Men started dropping on all sides,
dirt writ that my eyes and the clamor of explosions in bullets pounded against
my ears.
The Ridge we faced a lot was alive with an enemy that was impossible to see or
kill.
Captain May and shine kept forward,
crept forward.
He could see the chaos and disorder of our situation standing up with a cool,
purposeful manner.
He took charge.
He looked as calm as though he were directing a training maneuver.
At Camp Pendleton,
we organizing the company.
He directed a withdrawal from our untenable position.
He seemed to be everywhere at the proper moment moment,
personally assisting wounded,
making sure everyone got out of the Japs.
Captain Jimmy May in shine,
never ran out of courage and his selfless,
heroic actions saved.
Bravo company from destruction,
but he did run out of luck.
He was the last man still in the trap.
When he attempted to withdrawal towards our line,
Japanese soldiers used him for target practice.
Riddling his chest with multiple bullet wounds,
killing him,
reacting to the loss of our favorite officer.
The company found a collective fury and determination.
We organized,
we rushed to the offensive because we were too close for artillery,
fire support or airstrikes.
The fight developed in a classic as a classic marine infantry attack,
small clusters of men advanced by fire and fast movement until they found an
obliterated each concealed strong point or individual enemy,
soldier
van's gun.
Suddenly stopped looking their way.
I saw that he and Steve were down.
Suddenly I was overwhelmed with rage and all the anger I had stored up against
the Japanese burst out without fog or hesitation,
I sprinted into vans position.
Van had been hitting the back near the right shoulder and the rounded exited his
left side.
Steve had been gut shot twice and it was white with shock.
By reflex.
He was holding his hands to his stomach to stem the bleeding blood poured out
around his fingers.
As he pulled his legs into the fetal position,
I could see the pain on his pinched face knowing that the Japs would shoot
Steven van as they rolled around on the ground.
I grabbed their machine gun into my arms and fired from the hip like Basilone
did.
Sending led into the cave to suppress enemy fire.
I was in a hot rage and swivel the gun about so it's bullets would ricochet
throughout the cave and decimate those bastards who shot my friends.
Clouds of rock dust bill owed from the caves mouth.
I poured fire into the caves,
black mouth until the belt round out for a second.
I stood there,
the 30 cows barrel smoking,
the jabs who had shot Steve and van were silent.
Nothing came from the cave.
No bonzai charges,
no moans,
nothing,
just smoke and dust.
My sense is returned,
dropping the gun.
I turned to Steve and van.
I knew they were dying.
I screamed.
Corpsman
with the cow with the cave suppressed and the area safe dock marsh ran to Steve
and knelt over him.
Then turned to van seconds tick past seeming like hours.
I waited for docs,
orders her grant out to join us and me and marsh drag van and Steve to cover
marsh injected van with morphine.
While I broke open Steve Steve's first aid kit and handed the survey surette to
marsh,
he shoved the needle into Steve's flesh.
I screamed,
stretcher bearers
this day of violence,
fear killing,
and maiming left me on the edge of despair.
Sergeant Wyndell talk to me in a personal and marine way.
Tatum.
He said,
let's go.
We've got a job to do.
My mind slipped into a protective mode when events beyond my control took over.
From that afternoon on,
I purposely tried to avoid getting to know the replacement Ammo humper and the
marines filling the slots of those we had lost.
I didn't want to know their names,
where they were from or to see their girlfriends pictures.
I didn't want to get attached to them and suffer through the loss of close
friends again.
The war was still going on 30 feet ahead.
I wanted revenge
unseen.
Our enemy continued to punish us as we consolidated our gains for the day and
attempted to clear the newly seize territory.
A new private,
a replacement called me to the edge of a bluff.
He had spotted enemy soldiers clustered in a pill box and was trying to show me
their location.
I couldn't see what he had found and was siting down his arm while he pointed
our heads side by side.
All of a sudden a crack ring out.
He jerked forward and was dead before I could catch him.
A sniper's bullet had hit him between the eyes.
Instinctively.
I called for a corpsman,
although the man was beyond help
when the medic came up,
he said,
I can't take it anymore.
I can't go on if they want to,
they can just shoot me right now.
The blood that covered the medics uniform wasn't his own.
Medics are considered noncombatants under international law,
but the Japs didn't care about international law.
After 10 days on ie,
whoa,
he hadn't fired a shot.
He was too busy stopping the flow of other's blood.
I didn't know what to tell him.
I put my arm around his shoulders and said,
I understand
it didn't seem to help.
Staring straight ahead.
He cried.
I just want out of this war
than someone else yelled corpsman.
The medic dried his eyes,
picked up as kit and left to go patch up another wounded marine.
Now it's 12 days into the invasion,
so d plus 12
March 3rd was a bad day for replacement officers.
Lieutenants,
Garcia,
Harrington,
and Leech.
All assigned from the 27th replacement draft were killed in action
with almost no experience commanding troops in combat or anywhere else.
Second lieutenants had been cranked out of officer candidate school in Quantico,
Virginia wholesale.
The Marine Corps created it's new leaders with assembly line speed.
Okay.
Harrington and leach were commissioned officers for five months when they were
told to lead platoons and deadly combat.
Brave,
inexperienced pinch hitters or substitute quarter back's in a game of death.
They never even knew the men they were trying to lead.
Now we get to the 14th day
by mid morning.
Word swept through our ranks.
Colonel Butler has been killed.
Butler had been riding in a jeep to a conference at the regimental command post
in order to save time.
Along the way,
he decided to check out the terrain he participated would be his men's next
objective when the vehicle approach to trail junction near our old sugar mill,
his party took a direct 47 millimeter round hit from a Japanese anti tank and he
was killed instantly.
The driver,
an NCO accompanying him were seriously wounded.
It was another [inaudible] tragedy,
but not the last.
Shortly after Colonel Butler's death,
a sniper killed my squad mate and Camp Toro or a placement PFC lavor Jenkins of
freedom.
Freedom,
Wyoming.
As he rested between assaults,
the war was 18 days short of celebrating his first year in the core
Jenkins loss meant the first squad was down to three members,
Billy Joe Cawthorne,
our baby face marine,
go for Gus Henderson and Ralph Jeffers.
Now they were actually pulled off the line for a bit and had a little bit of a
rest.
During our day of rest.
My headache grew worse and I consulted a corpsman.
My ears ring.
I told him not impressed.
He answered,
it's normal for ears to ring in combat.
He gave me some aspirin for my headache and asked anything else wrong?
I showed him my leg wound.
He jokingly said,
too bad you're wound isn't deeper.
If it was,
you'd have a ticket off this damned island.
The aspirin didn't touch my headache.
It grew worse.
My ears rang constantly and I felt nauseous.
I was getting weaker and I knew it,
and so what we've got now is the initial stages of combat fatigue.
He starting to feel it
when Charmella says one of his other guys.
When trellis gave me hell about something or another,
my mind was hazy and numb.
I didn't answer him
about mid day.
The word came down.
Move out.
Okay.
Our Day of rest was over,
I reckon.
Ruefully we formed up to move out in a spread formation and immediately began
taking mortar fire.
I mean,
it's just a nightmare.
Take cover.
Window hollered has and we scattered like a Covey of quail seeking refuge
around,
hit a few yards from me.
My pulse raced and my battle senses told me to move,
sprinting.
I ran for a rock outcropping 30 yards away when I was halfway to safety.
A close round knocked me to the ground more than an artillery shelling.
It scared the hell out of me since d day,
but their fear I felt now was different.
My hands trembled.
Okay.
Fortunately the barrage stopped quickly.
I chain smoke to settle down.
My head pounded and I go down canteen,
water until my stomach was upset.
My legs felt paralyzed like a childhood nightmare in which I wanted to run but
couldn't.
Yeah,
the company moved out,
but I stayed where I was.
All I could think was fuck the war.
Fuck the Japs and fuck this whole island,
a flood of ever have other fuck everything searched through my tangled thinking
process.
Then awareness that I was alone and the fear of becoming a snipers,
snipers target prompted me to move.
There was another conclusion.
If I stayed where I was,
the Marine Corps would shoot me as a dessert.
Okay.
Self preservation instincts kicking in.
I told myself,
get off your butt and start moving.
I looked for my vanished company.
Eventually I heard someone calling my name
through the hazy vision.
I saw sergeant window walking toward me
when he was close enough.
He looked at me,
date him,
are you okay?
He asked,
let's join the company and don't worry.
You're going to be okay.
You're gonna make it.
I followed him without argument or objection
before we sat in for the evening at 3:30 PM window said to me,
Tatum,
I'm sending you back.
Glancing at Trellis.
He added,
you're Outta here too.
You're both finished.
Get the hell back.
Both of you.
The trek to the rear at Red Beach to our starting point 15 days ago,
took an hour.
There were no tears in my eyes.
I had combat fatigue.
Okay,
so
they're done and they get pulled off the island.
They get put onto a ship so they can recover mentally from what they've been
through.
So they're out there on this ship and obviously they're out there with a bunch
of other marines.
Been wounded
back to the book.
Tremendous.
And I felt completely out of place.
We were among seriously wounded marines and I almost felt guilty that I wasn't
wounded physically.
Our wounds were to our minds and there were no bandages that could be applied to
them.
There were no drugs that we could take that would erase the images of war that
filled our heads.
Mother Nature,
with assistance from modern medicine,
could he all the flesh,
but the mind is different.
You can never forget the pain you suffered in a place like he will Jima and the
scars will always be there.
Tremendous.
And I had been labeled s s c f or shell shocked.
Combat Fatigue.
Yeah.
This label had a negative connotation.
I suppose.
This was the result of the general misunderstanding of this type of condition.
It did not denote a lack of courage or resolve to fight who was a condition
caused by the inability to continue past physical or mental exhaustion.
Most marines who suffered combat fatigue,
we're the ones who had survived to fight another day and another day and another
day.
The lucky ones got the million dollar wound on the first day and live to
recover.
They didn't go back into the siege time and time again as tremendous and I had
done each day to see the decimation of young lives.
The deaths of buddies who were closer than brothers,
boys who's parents hopes would be dashed by a message from the navy saying,
we regret to inform you.
Most people never have to witness the killing of someone are close to a loved
one who was shot or decapitated.
Watch a brother whose face is filled by the look of deep shock that proceeds
death.
They never feel the helplessness of watching life bleed out of a mortal being.
Okay.
Those who know war,
no of what I speak.
I decided on side Pan that I would never apologize for my actions on Evil Jima
or for falling prey to combat fatigue.
I gave it my all.
Yeah.
Obviously in this day and age we've been dealing with a lot of combat fatigue,
PTSD
and I think one thing is I,
as I read through this,
I thought back to
Colonel Hackworth Book and about face and one of the ways that he describes it
is he says that basically people have a cup
and different size cups.
Different people have different sized cups and the Cup starts to get filled up
and if it gets filled up,
it's done.
You're done.
You can't take anymore and you just got to go away.
And this was the first time as I read this,
obviously chuck Tatum showed extreme courage over and over again and he points
out the fact that there's not that many guys that went day after day after day
after day and we're lucky enough to not get wounded or I guess you could say
unlucky enough.
Yeah.
It eventually they reach,
they reach a point where they can't take anymore.
Now you do get some guys that can handle more,
and I thought of this today,
okay.
It's each just nature,
right?
It's just how you're,
how you're formed.
And I'm not going to be mad at someone because they can't bench press 500
pounds,
right?
Some people don't have that.
That's not part of their physical makeup.
That's not far to their part of their physical constitution or their mental
constitution.
And it's the same thing here.
Some people just have a higher propensity for this type of mental stress so they
can handle it more.
Hmm.
And that doesn't mean that you know someone that can't bench press 500 pounds
like me doesn't mean I'm a pathetic person.
No,
it just means that I don't,
I just didn't naturally inherit those genetics that give me the ability to bench
press 500 pounds.
Now it's the same thing with what you inherit mentally.
In some people,
their cup gets filled up,
especially when they are lucky or unlucky enough.
As we just discussed to survive day after day,
after day after day,
and 14 days of thinking that you're going to die than seeing your friends get
wounded or killed.
Yeah.
And even back,
uh,
back then.
Okay.
How he said it had a negative connotation,
almost like you weren't mentally tough enough.
Right.
Like you had the luxury of not getting shot and all this stuff.
And you still couldn't hack it.
Almost in my point is number one,
to support what he says.
Yeah.
You've taken anybody,
anybody's going to have a breaking point.
Yeah.
And the breaking points are going to be at different spots.
And he was like,
like we're saying,
he was either unlucky or lucky enough,
depending on how you look at it to survive 14 straight days of this.
Yep.
And that was where he wrote some people would reach a breaking point in five
days,
but we never would know that.
Yeah.
Some people would last a hundred days,
but we wouldn't know that because they got killed.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
the,
when you get hit,
how you called it,
the million dollar wound white.
So when you get hit,
everyone's gonna recover,
recover from that,
the flash and modern medicine,
you know,
it heals it.
So yeah,
they,
that's why he called it the million dollar wound.
Cause it's like in a way you locked out.
Yup.
You know,
you didn't have to face these
terrible horrors that light beyond day 10 day 11 for 1415 you know?
Yup.
And then it,
and it just keeps going until you fall off.
Yeah.
Daddy.
And you're going to break at some point,
you know,
and everyone is,
and like I said,
it's just the way you're made up as your genetic code.
Maybe you can take it for seven days,
maybe you can take it for 28 days.
But the most important thing that he says that if there's vets out there that
think,
man,
I didn't do enough wrong.
Listen to what he says.
I decided on side and that's where they were now to recover.
I decided on Psi pawn that I would never apologize for my actions on an owe Jima
or for falling prey to combat fatigue.
I gave it my all
and that's all anybody could ask.
Now he dedicates to this book.
Cool.
And here's the book,
dedication.
This book is dedicated to my brothers,
the marines,
who fought the Japanese army on one of the darkest islands on earth.
[inaudible]
yeah.
On our voyage to iie.
Whoa.
We had dreams and plans for our futures.
We were young and buoyant.
Our hearts were filled with love for our families,
our buddies,
our country.
We want it to survive,
to come home together.
Then we felt the flames of that Pacific inferno
to my marine brothers who fell on that rock
I owe every day of the life.
I've led to you
semper fi.
And here is
a roster of some of the people that he knew.
Bonnie will Jima.
Lieutenant Colonel John Butler.
First Battalion commanding officer killed in action.
Captain James.
Jimmy may in shine,
killed an action.
Second Lieutenant John,
a Drager died of wounds.
Gunnery Sergeant Stanley Blackie Cavaretto died of wounds.
Gunnery Sergeant John Baz alone killed in action.
Pfc Bruno.
Spike mears was killed in action.
Pfc Loyal Lamon
killed an action.
Pfc Clifford.
Steve Evanson
killed in action.
Okay.
Pfc Carl Texts Thompson
killed in action.
Corporal Frank Posts.
Pickle killed in action.
PFC Lavar Jenkins killed in action.
Corporal George Shelf.
Okay.
Killed in action.
Private Ralph Jeffers
killed in action.
Pfc Edward J.
Tucker
killed in action
and those are some of the names,
some of the people
of the 6,821 sailors and marines that were killed in action
on a place where the Marine Corps awarded 27
okay.
Medal of honors,
which was a quarter of all the medal of honors that were awarded during World
War II.
I didn't want to close this out.
Not with a medal of honor citation,
but with a silver star citation.
Okay.
For Pfc Edward J.
Tucker
for conspicuous gallantry and intrepid as a squad leader serving April tune of
company Bravo First Battalion 27th Marines,
Fifth Marine Division in action against Japanese enemy forces on the woe Jima
volcano islands 14 March,
he lists of his own painful wounds and refusing evacuation in order to remain
with his men in continuance of an assault against the bitterly defending
Japanese private FirstClass.
Tucker on hesitatingly braved a deadly hail of hostile fought rifle.
Fire and machine gun fire to rescue a wounded marine lying in an exposed
position,
although mortally wounded while administering first aid to is stricken comrade
private first class Tucker by his unselfishness courage and devotion to duty had
strengthened in a morale and fighting spirit of his entire company,
thereby reflecting great credit upon himself
and the United States naval service.
So
as I have said,
and as I always say,
war brings out the worst in us,
but it can also bring out the best.
And there are thousands and thousands of heroes
like PFC Edward J.
Tucker,
known and unknown
that have made the ultimate sacrifice
for our country,
for the Marine Corps,
for their battalion,
their company,
their platoon squad,
and for their friends.
And I want you to remember that too,
that in all that darkness,
in that black sand and all that evil in the world,
they are our heroes and brave men and men that don't take lives
but give their lives for their friends.
And while we do talk about evil,
also always remember
that the world is also filled more filled with good men and good women and good
people.
And remember those people
in moments of darkness and temptation,
let them
inspire you to follow in their footsteps
because there's no doubt
that the example
has been set.
So
it's,
it's really just a,
uh,
another situation when I,
when I think about the dichotomy of war and the dichotomy,
a combat
and how it brings out the worst in people,
but it also brings out the best in people.
And I think that in order to appreciate the best in people,
you got to recognize what they're up against.
Got to recognize what we're up against.
And you got to see that example,
that example of people that shine,
they shine
in those circumstances.
And if they can rise like that in those circumstances,
in those situations facing such horror.
Okay,
well then maybe we can rise a little too.
It may be we can shine just a little bit brighter
and bring a little bit more light
into the world.
And I'd say,
Echo,
it looks like I set us up for another rough transition here.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
My apologies.
But it'll offer a bit of a contrast,
right?
Yes.
We will,
uh,
like I said,
this reflects life.
Yeah.
And you go through horrible things and you'll be facing some tough times.
That's what life does to you.
You know,
and then a little while later you'll be laughing,
you know?
And that's the way life is.
Yeah.
That's the way this podcast seems to go to.
You have a bad day at work.
You come home,
boom,
your son and daughter's got straight A's.
There you go.
We've got their report card.
Right.
Okay.
You got to dig that.
Yeah.
Let's go to the interweb questions.
Cool.
But before that,
I do have to let you know Jocko,
just in case you didn't know what we are sponsored by on it.
I like that.
If you didn't know what that is,
that's where I get my Alpha Bri.
I'm so smart.
I'm good memory.
Um,
on it.com/jocko,
if you want 10% off your on it stuff,
and that's Alpha brain warrior bars.
If you didn't know what that is,
Krill oil,
keep your joints working as time goes on.
Strong bone.
Don't forget about that.
What,
what is strong?
Just some Krill or stuff for your joints where you joined.
You should know addition to,
yeah,
I liked the Alpha brain worry bars.
Just do your feet.
Just try that.
Beet juice.
Try.
That's all I'm going to fit in wherever.
Look into his man.
Yeah.
No donuts whereby it's bull.
Um,
they also have coffee now,
which is dope.
That's right.
Now you can get after it with some coffee.
[inaudible]
dot com slash Jacko 10% off.
Oh.
Also Internet related stuff in the event of you wanting to support this podcast
in anyway,
here's some ways you can shop at Amazon before you go to Amazon,
go to Jocko podcast.com or [inaudible] dot com click on the Amazon link.
You don't pay anything extra.
You just kind of sit passively support this podcast if you want it.
It's actively
no cause you're shopping.
Yeah.
One Click.
One Click of action.
Yeah.
Supports the podcast.
Fee that everybody buys everything with Amazon.
Yeah.
It's one of the things we're doing a little does a lot,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
Echo with all kinds of good knowledge tonight.
Yup.
Or if you want some shirts that I v I think they're cool.
Okay.
Jocko,
store.com get some shirts if you think they're even half as cool as I think they
are,
or a coffee Mug,
it says up before the enemy on it.
It's pretty cool.
Anyway,
in that question,
let's do it.
Alpha brain gives you a weird dreams,
by the way,
if you take it before you get to sleep,
I take it,
I have weird dreams regardless of Ray Ray.
Okay.
Actually,
you know what?
They don't give you weird dreams.
They give you a weird awareness of your dreams.
Oh,
I'm not making that as like an official claim.
I'm saying that's what happens with me and that's what I hear.
Literally everyone else who takes before they go to bed.
Yeah.
That doesn't really happen to me for some reason because it's not,
it's not a stimulant.
By the way.
You still go to sleep.
Good.
Yeah.
I take it before I go to bed.
Cool.
You know,
that's why you're so smart.
Jocko.
I want to hear your thoughts on over detachment.
Okay.
I'm a police officer and I'm sure military personnel experience the same over
detachment defined as emotional separation from moments which requires emotional
response in family and profession.
So what are you thoughts on over detachment?
Yeah,
this is definitely,
obviously I'm always encouraging people to be able to detach,
right?
Because that's how you get your emotions out of a situation.
But this happens to what my brother right here is talking about this police
officer's saying,
hey,
sometimes you know,
we think about being over detached
and is something you need to watch out for because you don't want to go through
your life where you have no more emotions.
Cause then you're not living your life.
Then you're a robot or a machine and,
and you don't,
you need to have emotions.
So what as I thought about this,
I thought,
how did I watch out for that?
And it's something that creeps in on anybody that does anything.
We could,
you don't even have to be a cop or a or military personnel.
I mean you could do,
if you're any job that you have where you have free,
can't just get all emotional about stuff.
Um,
if you're in finance,
if you're anything you could just become detached.
So how do you do,
what do you look out for?
What one thing that I did,
okay,
it's still do is compartmentalize and draw little segregation between work and
home.
Um,
and there's a really easy way to do that,
especially for people that are cops or it doesn't matter what you do.
Okay.
Whatever that uniform is that you wear at work.
Whether you're a cop,
whether you're military,
whether you're wearing a business suit at work,
when you get home,
take off that uniform,
take it off.
Matter of fact,
if you can't take it off before you get home,
you know,
leave it at the office.
Yeah.
Cause you want to leave that there.
And when you get home,
put on the home clothes,
right?
The t shirt,
the comfortable t shirt,
the flip
flops,
the the shorts B,
be relaxed at home,
but be physically in a different uniform at home.
Not even a uniform in a different change your change your appearance and
therefore change your state of mind a little bit different music,
right?
Whatever it is that you're listened to at work,
go to something different at home.
Yeah.
You know when you're going into work,
listen to the first hour of Jocko podcasts when you're coming home,
he listened to the second hour,
right?
That's how we do it.
Yo,
you want to have a different attitude,
a different language,
right?
Don't come home thrown around the anachronisms from work.
And you know what?
I've talked about this before.
I never swore at home.
I swore like hell at work,
but it never swore at him.
So I was using a different language than I was completely compartmentalizing
what I was doing at work and when I was doing at home.
And then check out your posture.
What are you standing around your house like?
Are you stand in all cross armed and glaring at people?
Yeah.
Let's just ask the question.
Are you in a modified weaver stance when you're talking to your wife,
getting ready to do a quick drawing?
It's like a pistol shooting stance.
That's,
no,
no.
You know,
are you,
are you digging for under hooks?
If your kids give you a hug,
you know what I mean?
Are you looking to get the tape down?
No.
You want to relax,
right?
And another thing is to find some,
uh,
you know,
what's maybe maybe group of people that aren't involved in your work.
And that can be hard.
I mean,
and,
and luckily for me,
my wife made friends that were outside of the seal community.
And so I got a bunch of buddies that were,
had nothing to do with the seal teams because they were friends of the friends
of my wife's friends and husbands of my wife's friends.
So I had a whole group of people that are still hanging out with all the time.
They have nothing to do with the military at all.
In fact,
many of them are as bad as far as you could get from military personnel as one
could imagine.
And,
but that's another thing that helped me segregate the two.
Now,
of course,
I'm not saying you've got to let your guard down 100%,
cause you shouldn't do that,
but you should let it down enough that you can enjoy life.
Um,
and uh,
you got it attached sometimes.
Now that being said,
cause it's Kinda,
hey,
it is going to help you make good decisions.
But there are also times where it's not good and if you're detached and your
wife's trying to talk to you,
it's not going to be good.
Yup.
So open up,
you got to show some emotions.
And one of the things about being detached,
here's a,
here's a paradox.
You gotta be detached enough so that you recognize when you're not showing
enough emotion.
You know what I'm saying?
If you're,
if you're so detached that you being detached,
it allow you to realize that,
oh my God,
I'm not showing any emotions at all.
I'm too detached.
Yeah.
So don't try and be a tough guy that's just
been detached.
Cause if you're detached enough,
you'll realize that you're being too detached.
Yep.
Yeah.
And there is two d the wall obviously like if you're,
you know,
you're in a debate argument,
fight,
whatever with your girlfriend wife,
right?
And you're detached,
let's say,
you know you're right.
Let's say you are right.
That has nothing to do with anything when you're arguing with you.
Generally speaking though,
in my experience,
yes I would agree with that in my experience.
But here's the thing though,
because you're looking at a certain way.
I just want to make that same again.
When you're an argument with your wife or your close friend or any east to your
boss or your subordinate,
whether you're right or not is almost,
doesn't matter at all.
What matters is what you're trying to do,
what the direction you're trying to move and is winning the argument being right
or wrong,
going to help you move in the direction where I'm moving.
That's the real question.
Yeah.
So detach for a minute and figure out the answer to that question.
Yes.
Cause I never care if I'm right or wrong.
That's not never my goal.
Well,
in an argument with something,
did I say never?
I usually don't care the most for the most park.
Yeah.
And,
and I think a lot of times,
a lot of times people do care whether right or wrong.
Oh my God,
do they care who can go psycho,
right?
Being right or wrong,
proved beyond a reasonable doubt.
All questions denied.
I'm 100% right.
You're wrong.
And so even when people are wrong,
they'll still want to just win the argument,
right?
So that's,
that's,
that's bad.
What can be even worse is when you are right,
yet the other person is a it,
let's say your wife has emotional cause and this is a known thing that
the girls generally speaking,
they,
they want to know that you care more so than they want you to fix their problem.
Like if someone has,
if your wife is having a problem at work or something,
right?
They just want you to care that that's going on with them.
They don't want like all this tricky advice.
You know,
generally speaking,
I'm not going to categories there is not black and white,
but generally speaking,
so let's say you're in a debate or something.
I say you're in an argument,
you're in a fight and you know you're right and let's say you are right.
If you're all detached and being like,
well,
here's the logic behind why I'm right and you have this airtight case that's not
going to help your relationship.
She wants to know first off that you care.
She's mad.
She said she's whatever.
Do you care about that?
That's the way you win,
not the argument.
That's the way you win the situation.
Yes.
You know?
And so not only are you,
not only do you get out of the fight intact as a relationship,
but you're the good guy.
And really that's part of the reason why she likes you,
because you're the good guy.
That's a win win.
So yeah,
that,
that's just something I'm questioning why my wife likes me.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that's,
that's a,
that's it.
But yeah,
so,
so you see that,
but be attached because you care.
Yes.
And show that you care.
And then when you go back to work,
you're your comp Europe military person.
You're a businessperson.
Put your uniform back on,
put your boots back on.
Put your body armor back on lock and load and get back into detachment zone
and move forward.
Now at the question kind of implies this too.
And I will point this out.
I mean at work you also can't just be detached all the time cause you're,
you're a leader,
you're in a leadership position and so you can't just walk around just detached
from every,
no.
You got to show emotions.
You've got to relate to the people you're working with.
You've got to be a human so that they follow you or you follow them or whatever
the case may be.
So the detachment,
you have to be detached enough to recognize when you're being too detached,
less hair.
And the question
I was hoping to get your thoughts on bullying.
If your child is being bullied,
what would you tell him or her?
This is,
I guess a little bit of a softball for me to throw this question out of it.
Cause I,
you know what I'm going to say,
get your kid into Jitsu.
You couldn't it to immediately,
um,
get them in there and let them start to learn what it's like to deal with people
physically and it will build up their confidence and it won't be a false
confidence.
It'll be a real confidence because they will know how to handle themselves.
They will have people that are trying to take them down to the ground and trying
to choke them and they will learn to stop that from happening and they will
learn to do it to other people when warranted,
you know?
So that's how you prevent bullying in my opinion.
You also get him to start doing pullups pushups,
dips.
You get them to do a little bit of boxing,
maybe even a little more tight.
I'll tell you,
at our gym over the years we've probably had half a dozen kids that have come in
specifically because they were getting bullied at school.
And every one of those cases within three months,
four months,
maybe six months at the outset,
the parents are coming to me and saying he's not getting bullied anymore.
And there sometimes there's that,
that,
that incident where I've had a few students that have,
you know,
and these are kids are 10 years old getting picked on,
getting picked on,
getting picked on and all of a sudden they started training Jujitsu and then one
day they choke out the bully.
Hmm.
And they never get picked on again.
Yep.
And they're confident and they're not jerks about it.
They become defenders cause they know what it's like to be bullied.
So they don't like to see other people get bullied,
you know?
So I would say,
you know,
get your kids into Jujitsu if they're getting bullied and it will not only teach
them to prevent themselves from being bullied,
it will prevent them from becoming a bully.
Yeah.
Because they'll recognize what it's like and what the power of physical
intimidation is.
Yeah.
And they will not like it.
And,
and I would say it would help them not become a bully because a lot of stuff
that goes on at home,
you know,
everyone's different.
Everyone's family is different.
But a lot of times bullies,
people,
kids that become beliefs,
they're bullied at home.
So being a bully is just a result of something else,
you know?
So yeah,
Jude too,
because it helps your cut your confidence in your security as a kid.
So you will feel less insecure if you're an insecure kit.
So that alone is really powerful.
Even if you are prone to becoming a bully.
And this is kind of this kind of well known,
I think it's pretty well known that usually when you're bullied,
like when someone's bullying someone else,
even adults,
it's not necessarily about beating them up and picking on him,
beating him up.
It's,
it's less about the physical part of it and more about just the mental power
with the power trip.
So when you learn Jujitsu,
and man,
I'm telling you I wasn't really bullied or nothing like that,
but when you start to know Jujitsu,
you have it in your head.
It's,
it's almost like you can't help but just radiate that kind of secure confidence.
So when if you like,
if you're,
if you roll in and you know Jujitsu now and a bully tries to believe,
he will gather immediately and there's programs like specific programs having to
do what you did to cope,
you know,
bulletproof and all the stunt men.
Just generally speaking,
you learned this in Jujitsu where you just basically,
you just stand your ground and you basically,
you can,
there's all these different ways to do it,
but you call out the bullied,
like,
are you,
are you trying to fight me right now?
And just standing up to them,
we'll usually stop the bullying because if they believe you in,
you're like,
oh,
and I'll tell you this.
Even though a majority of the bullying is verbal or mental or psychological,
yeah,
it's all on the premise.
All the bullying is built on the premise most of the time that I can physically
beat you,
so therefore you can't do anything.
Yeah.
Occasionally you'll get some young,
keep scrappy little loud mouth kid that just bullies people just on the fact
that they just don't care.
Right.
That's a rare,
that's a rare breed.
Most bullies.
They feel like they can physically when and therefore they can mentally abuse
people.
Yep.
And once that,
once the,
once the victim realizes,
you know what,
I can actually take this person out.
The whole dynamic changes.
Yeah.
And just that,
that,
that first stage of standing up to him just even verbally,
that's only in the belief of mine.
That's a little indicator I carried him only the sky,
but some believes they might be like,
hey,
a size advantage.
This guy's just feeling a little triumphant today and he's going to try to stand
up to me and then they'll,
they'll push it and then when you know that you Jitsu it,
man,
you can deal with bullies really easy.
As a kid.
W leg take down mount.
Yeah.
Slap to the faces.
Men Naked.
Choke.
I wish I knew it when,
when I was a little kid.
It teaches you perfectly where to be and where not to be,
where you just control the fight.
Okay.
Can Be big and Oh man,
I wish I started when I was,
I wish he was around on us.
Yeah.
Next question.
How do I deal with being in an environment I'm forced to be in many,
I'm 1818 years old and I have one year of school left.
High School is just a place I perish in.
It kills creativity.
All of the information taught is easily obtainable on the Internet.
I don't feel like I have any purpose in school.
Learning things that oh be of that will be little of little to no use in my life
for eight hours a day.
Just seems dumb in having Asperger's and Adhd doesn't make sitting in a math
class for 90 minutes easier.
Also,
most people are in,
are not about achievement,
motivation or anything,
but would rather play it safe and stay in our small town all their life.
We'd love to hear your thoughts on a forced environment.
Well,
I will tell you that the thoughts contained in that paragraph probably
encapsulate a large,
large number of humans in,
you know,
high school,
myself being included in that group.
Myself and my buddies,
when we were growing up,
we didn't want to be in high school.
We wanted to get out.
We want to get after it.
We want to do,
whether we want to see the world,
we wanted to make things happen,
right?
Not necessarily good things either,
but just things sneak it out.
We just wanted to make stuff happen.
And you know,
when I hear this,
this is kind of very normal.
So first of all,
I'd be like,
hey man,
you're just feeling what normal people feel.
I mean,
not everybody,
because some people really enjoy high school,
they enjoy education.
Not a large number,
but some people recognize that it's a,
it's an opportunity.
You know,
high school is an opportunity and it's an opportunity to learn and it's an
opportunity to hang out and meet people and you know,
kind of live that part of your life.
I mean,
it is one of the most relaxing things.
It's one of the most relaxing phases of life,
right?
You just have nothing,
you know,
pressure.
Um,
and a,
I say no pressure.
And when you're in high school,
you're like,
well,
no,
I had to take a test or homework.
Exactly the same.
Right?
Uh,
this is another thing that I always think about with forced environment.
So I,
when I was a kid,
I worked construction and you know,
uh,
some of the guys I work construction with were pretty rough characters and one
of them had dona fair amount of time in prison in one of the things that he said
to me was,
you know,
when you're in prison,
if you stand right next to the bars in your cell,
if you stand right next to him
then
you're locked in there.
But if you walk back away from the bars and you see
what kind of freedom you got inside that cell,
even though it's small,
it's bigger than when you stand right next to the bars.
So I always had this feeling of,
you know,
just step back from the bars a little bit.
And I've actually explained that to some of buddies of mine when we,
they would feel trapped in the navy,
you know,
cause even the seal teams,
I love that,
you know,
but guys would sometimes start feeling trapped in them,
that navy and I'd say,
I'd say,
we know what,
if you want to get out,
get out,
give yourself an out if you want to.
But just then assess it from a position where you say,
you know what,
I could get out if I want it to.
So don't stand so close to the parts,
like I'm stuck in the navy step back and go,
you know what?
If I want to get out and look it out,
and then they look at it and they go,
you know what?
Actually it's not a bad,
it's not a bad deal.
It's a pretty good deal.
And that's what I would do in a situation like this.
You look at going to high school,
I mean,
yeah,
you're trapped in school for eight hours a day,
but eight hours a day in school plus eight hours a day of sleep.
If you sleep that much,
that leaves you eight hours a day of doing whatever you want.
Right?
And that's awesome.
Plus you got weekends thrown in there,
so you got a lot of opportunity to do all kinds of things.
Going to high school for eight hours a day is a small price to pay for the
opportunities that you have while you're in high school.
So it's,
I don't view it really as a,
as a forced environment.
I viewed as an opportunity.
I mean,
do they got a gym there?
What?
You're going to learn something,
even if it's stuff that you could learn it on the Internet,
why not have a human teach it to you?
That's pretty cool.
You know,
you know,
just sit in that class and learn what you can get if you got eight ADHD and
Aspbergers okay,
let's see how our discipline can get control over that and we challenged
ourselves to work on the patients and work on paying attention.
Paying attention is a skill I learned that well in college.
It's a skill.
It's a skill to be able to sit down and read something that you do not want to
read.
It's a skill.
It's a skill to be able to sit into a class and listen to a lecture on the
subject that you do not want to listen to.
That takes me.
I just got a cool a Twitter that next time I'll try and remember it,
read it.
But it's a guy that was like,
hey,
I hated school and I'm going through this class right now and I got to write
these responses to these,
to these uh,
uh,
reading assignments that we've got.
And it was really bothering me.
And he said,
I was listening to podcasts and you're fired up about linguistics and fired up.
And so I said,
you know what?
I'm going to own this.
And now he's totally fired up to tear those,
tear those reading assignments apart and dig into and find out what the words
mean and he's killing it.
Now I'm in the same built by the way,
Jack,
that's outstanding.
So again,
you're not trapped unless you stand right next to those bars that are in front
of your face.
Step back away from the bars,
look around and see what kind of freedom you actually have.
And you've got a lot of freedom.
May Not feel like it.
Right,
but you got a lot of freedom,
you a lot of things to advantage of
from time to equipment to education.
Take advantage of all that stuff.
You've got another year left,
kill it,
make it happen.
And that's my advice to the senior in high school where you mentioned reading or
paying attention is a skill,
the skill,
and you mentioned reading stuff that you don't want to read.
And remember how I said it a few times back where
that's not that,
that's a common thing.
People would just,
I don't want to read,
I don't want to read a book.
You know that's not like that.
That's pretty common.
A lot of people would prefer not to read audio looks or whatever,
but if you're willing to read or you like to read,
I would even go beyond that.
Almost call that as a superpower.
Not like a super power,
like it's superhuman or anything,
but that's like an ed major advantage.
And I mentioned this where all the information you ever want to know is out
there and it you can access it.
If you know how to read,
you can access it,
but here's the thing like,
well then,
and everyone kind of knows that and one way or another people,
especially here in the u s you kind of know that information is ever all their
information.
Whether you understand it or not,
does a different thing.
This information can help you in probably 90 to 99% of anything you want to do.
It can help you become that,
achieve that,
all this information,
all you need,
this information and then you just act on it and do it right.
Then why isn't,
why aren't,
why isn't everyone just successful in everything they want to do and every
single way you can learn all the information,
you can learn all the skills by reading about it.
All of it right now,
lack of discipline because they'd want to read it.
Who wants to go to the library or get a book and read it?
2000 page book on economics,
even though if they were just to read that,
read it three times,
they would know exactly what to do,
what to invest in,
where the truck,
you'd know a lot,
you'd have some powerful information to become,
I don't know,
rich or,
or just make more money or whatever.
So the reason that people don't is because they don't want to read.
That's it.
Meanwhile,
and we've talked about this before,
meanwhile you have time,
you have time to read.
If you have time to watch TV,
If you have time to,
I dunno,
go to the beach or I dunno,
whatever you do in your spare time,
you have time to read.
Going to the,
going to the beach won't help you in ways that reading can help you and watching
reality TV can't help you as much as reading can help you.
But it's one of the things that it's viewed as such a chore,
I think for a lot of people.
Yeah.
It's viewed as a chore instead of being viewed as an opportunity.
And I think the reading,
like if someone could just inject all the information into your brain matrix and
people would do it,
you know,
but it's that reading.
That's the chore.
That's what they don't want to do.
So consider that.
Right.
He mentioned that all this is available on the Internet,
right?
But in school you,
you have a teacher who knows this information.
You can ask questions about it.
You can make w I've read stuff that I'm like,
well,
I don't really get what he means right there.
I'll read again.
I don't really get what they really get it.
I still didn't get what it means when it,
he means by this,
but at school you just raise your hand,
ask a question,
he'll explain it.
You don't,
I'm sorry.
Raise your hand again.
You can raise your hand out after everything the teacher says.
You can raise your hand and tell him.
Explain it again.
He's right there.
Every class.
Here's your opportunity right there.
Indeed,
sir.
Excellent Echo.
Fired up for the reading.
I like that.
I'm telling you man,
it's
flake.
One day is the light,
the lights on kind of new,
right?
It's new.
Yes.
This is post Jocko podcast because this post Jocko podcast and now you're just
absorbing information.
Right,
and it's not this thing where I started to start to get into reading it.
It was like,
like when you walk into the room,
the lights are off.
It's like,
oh,
there's nothing really in this room.
I don't see anything in this room.
You turn on the light,
you're like,
oh my gosh,
the all this was here this whole time.
I'm over here at this age.
I could've been doing this the whole time.
This reading.
You know where I'd be if I started doing this?
Oh,
I like,
oh my gosh,
this guy's an 18 denying it.
Keeping the light off.
Don't do that.
You don't have to do that.
Just all you got to just turn it on.
Good.
That's all you gotta do.
Good advice.
Jocko.
Does leadership required the atrics or acting skill in the case of an
underperforming subordinate?
I mean,
obviously in a way,
yes it does it,
but it's definitely more complicated in that as well because,
and we've talked about this before,
you know I've talked about like when,
if,
if you want to make an impression to your kids,
they haven't listened to you when you've told him 14 times in finally,
you know,
you've been all calm and detach and be like,
hey,
this is it.
This is why you give it down to everything you're supposed to do in the extreme
ownership hand handbook of leadership and they're still not listening to you and
you go,
you know what,
I've got to show some zoom anger here,
right?
So they realized that I'm really serious.
So that's a time where you might have to flip the switch and act right,
like your angry for instance.
You know,
this is part of detachment because if you are controlling your emotions and you
decide you need to show some emotions,
then you're going to need to do some sort of,
I guess it would be considered acting,
Beatrice some theatrical [inaudible] too
to make that clear now.
And also might go in the other direction where you don't want to show that
you're frustrated or you don't want to show that you're angry or you don't want
to shoot.
You know,
if you're,
if you got your team looking at you and you and your,
you don't want to show that you're frustrated or Colombia.
Yeah.
So you've got to act.
Okay,
I'm just,
you know,
I've got to act cool.
I've got to detach a little bit and just act cool.
And so
those are both,
I guess those could be considered acting,
but at the same time,
I don't think it's disingenuous.
And I will tell you why.
The reason I'll tell you why is because,
remember when I was on Sam Harris and we were talking about being brave and he,
I think it was,
he said,
if you pretend to be brave,
well then you are in fact being brave.
So if,
if,
if you're wounded in the street and there's machine gun fire going on and I say,
you know what?
I don't want to do this,
but I'm just going to pretend to be brave right now and I run out and grab you,
pull you out of the street.
Even though I was pretending to be brave,
I was brave because that's what I did.
I did the action.
It's the same thing here.
If I'm really angry at you,
but I decided,
you know what?
I got to keep that inside and I've got to act like I'm calm.
Well,
guess what?
What I did was that calm,
so therefore it's not acting.
That's what I did as a person.
So I guess I'm really not acting at all because I'm being,
me and me is detached and acting like I'm calm even though I'm super angry.
Yeah.
You are at kind of a weird paradox technique,
and I thought about this before you are acting,
but like just like are you saying it's not disingenuous because there's a
difference between what you feel and how you behave like feelings and behavior.
So if I'm mad at you for something and I don't yell at you and be all it,
does that mean I'm not mad at you?
It doesn't mean that.
Right?
But what if I,
I am mad at you and I did and I do my aim,
my madness,
my anger makes me yell at,
at you.
All that means is my feelings are driving my behavior.
Just because your feelings aren't driving your behavior,
it doesn't mean it's disingenuous.
You know?
So you can still be mad.
You can still yell even though the yelling isn't because you're a mad.
The yelling is for a specific result.
So we'll just like how you're saying you're still stand con.
Yes,
you're acting,
but you're acting because you want a certain result.
Yes.
That's what I say.
You are acting because you're,
you're gonna.
If,
if you're not acting,
that means that your anger is driving your behavior,
your feeling is driving your behavior behavior.
Otherwise you're just,
yeah,
you're acting.
But I think I agree with you when we were talking about it before it.
That's a good thing you're going for results here.
Yeah,
and that's the question.
The actual question is,
it specifically says under po underperforming subordinate and so clearly,
yeah,
you might have to show some anger so then they realize that you're really
serious that they may get fired,
that they need to improve,
that they need to whatever the case may be.
Yeah.
And yeah,
if it's with your girlfriend and wife,
it shows me you care a lot of times.
You know how like you'll be like,
hey,
you know,
say something and you're saying it.
Then I'll call him or whatever.
And caring,
knowing you care about or someone knowing that you care about them,
that is a big deal.
Versus
if they suspect,
I mean he doesn't care about the situation of Jelly.
No,
you're right to care.
People want you to care.
Jocko,
you got to care.
Next question.
At what point does loyalty and what could become martyrdom for a human that you
care about?
Become out,
waited with the desire to improve oneself,
put differently,
loyal to be there for loyal,
to be there for a loved one teammate,
employee,
et Cetera,
in a tough situation or downward spiral isn't important and admire bill train.
But when does it go too far that wants you to become selfish and begin to cut
those types?
This is a question that everybody's got to deal with at some point in their
life.
Yeah.
As soon as they do.
Obviously I'm all about helping people and doing everything you can to help
people out.
Right?
That's great.
Sure.
But you got to take care of yourself first.
And I think,
I think the thing that I think of is when you go on an airplane and they say,
Hey,
if we lose pressure in the cabin,
oxygen masks drop down.
And if you're with a child,
take care of yourself first,
then you can take your child.
So what happens if you don't take care of yourself first?
Then you pass out and now your child doesn't get helped.
And now you both die from lack of oxygen.
So that's sort of like life,
right?
If you've got somebody that's dragging that's going down a downward spiral and
you decide that you're just going to pour everything into them,
well then you're going to go down that downward spiral as well,
and now you're not going to be able to help him.
So I think you definitely have to get yourself.
You have to take care of yourself as a person so that you have the platform to
take care of someone else and help someone move in the right direction.
And so I don't think you can let yourself get dragged down too far right down
these paths.
You have to get the oxygen mask on yourself and stabilize yourself and have a
platform to help other people without getting dragged down.
And I'll tell you something else,
by the way,
oftentimes when you think you're helping someone,
mm hmm.
You really just enabling them and you know,
you see that with the addictive,
you know when people are in the case of addiction.
Yeah.
It's awful.
And the people that are trying to loved ones that are trying to help them by
saying,
okay,
look,
I'll,
I'm going to help you through them to give you a little bit more money right
now,
but this is the last time.
And then the next week it's,
I'll give you a little bit more money.
And all they're doing is buying booze or drugs or whatever addiction that they
have.
And it's horrible to see it.
You are actually,
even though you think you're helping them,
you're actually hurting them.
And so I think of,
I guess it's the big night for a detachment on the podcast here,
but you got to detach.
You've got to make sure you're not becoming an emotional,
you got to make sure that you're seeing the person and the situation for what it
really is,
not what you want it to be,
but what it really is,
who they really are,
what they are really doing.
And then when you're detached,
you got to make logical decisions from that point of detachment to decide
whether this person can be helped and how far you're willing to go to help them.
And you got to remember,
you can't be a hero to everybody.
Yeah.
And you can't help everybody all the time.
And again,
I want to help people out when they're in trouble,
but you need to maintain your own stability in life so that you have a platform
that you can help people.
Because if you burn down your platform and you throw away your stability,
not only will you not be able to help that person,
but you won't be able to help anybody,
including yourself eventually.
Yeah.
And you,
you say like you want to help them without letting them them drag you down too
far.
So that point,
that too far point is going to be different for everybody and every
relationship.
So I think you'd be kind of get a handle on that.
Like what is too far away?
What is being dragged down too far?
Is it getting in the way of these important things in my life?
Because yeah,
he's talking about when do you cut those ties?
That's,
you know,
that means you've been dragged down too far where you got to cut those ties.
Oh,
so I think,
I think that's important.
Um,
some people,
they're just,
that's kind of their thing.
You know,
they'll get dragged all the way down.
Some people like my work time to help you.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly.
Which can be fine,
I think.
I think if that,
that's people's kind of thing.
I think,
you know,
there's all kinds of different people and I think that that,
because I think it drags both parties into the,
into the darkness.
Yeah.
If they go all the way down,
like,
you know,
they lose some important stuff in their life.
But at jobs,
finances,
yeah.
Uh,
stability,
but some people they,
they,
you know,
it's like that's kind of there.
I don't want to see their lot in life cause it sounds kind of like it's a bad
thing.
It's their addiction.
Yeah.
It's like the thing they like it.
So there's that.
Um,
so helping versus enabling,
right.
So there's two kinds of like,
correction,
and I might get the terms wrong,
but it's,
it's direct help in the systemic help.
So direct help is like the sort of superficial obvious health,
like take the,
take the consideration of um,
like giving money to a homeless person,
right?
Where if you,
if someone who has a cup and it's like,
you know,
help me,
give me,
give me money.
Basically I put five bucks in the house in the cup.
Right?
So that's,
that's direct versus systemic.
Systemic would be,
okay,
I'm going to contribute to a soup kitchen.
Yeah.
Or no more.
No.
Even go more systemic than that.
So I'm going to contribute to a,
that gets people on their feet basically giving people the tools to help
themselves.
Right?
So that's systemic that that goes,
that doesn't solve the superficial problem.
It's like,
it's like instead of watering the leaves you out of the roots,
it's that.
So instead of giving money to a homeless person,
which can potentially the worse.
Yes.
Because just like what enabling is,
look,
if I'm a homeless guy,
I'm like,
hey look,
I'm whatever,
whatever my situation,
I'm a homeless guy and bay asking for money.
I make 50 bucks today at this corner.
I'm going to come back tomorrow and make my 50 bucks.
I have no other skills.
If I,
if you want to help them,
if you,
what if someone came and instead of 50 bucks or five bucks or dollar,
whatever,
they gave me some skills.
However they did,
I don't know,
a magical pill and it gave me some skills.
So I dunno,
I knew how to sell real estate or something.
I Dunno.
I'd go use those skills and boom,
then I'm helped,
you know.
So yeah,
the helping versus enabling.
I think he got to put it into perspective and give it a lot of thought when you
help someone.
And I think that people who enable people or who accidentally enabled people,
all that is them not putting enough thought into it,
how to help them.
Cause a lot of times they really care.
But they ended up enabling them and on top of it with,
which makes it more of a challenge for people,
enabling the people they care about is they get a payoff from giving them,
you know,
whatever it is,
they give them more or lying for him or doing this other stuff's like I helped
him for that day.
So it gives them that,
that payoff a little feel good.
Yeah.
I helped him that day.
I gave the home l man,
he's so nice he gave that,
that homeless guy five bucks.
Oh Dang.
Everyone's giving change.
He's over here giving them five bucks when really,
I'm not saying all the time,
but potentially you could have basically just made that corner more valuable for
him to work.
Potentially say it all the time.
So like I said,
I think something that would help is put in the thought with how you want to
help.
So if you can help systemically,
that's um,
that's the way to help better,
it's a better way to help in my opinion.
All right,
next question Jocko.
How do you get over feeling like an imposter?
As a new manager,
I feel like I'm about to get found out.
Welcome to leadership,
my friend.
Here's the thing,
here's what you're actually scared of.
What you're scared of most likely is them knowing and finding out that you don't
know everything.
Right?
Right.
That's what people don't like to admit when they're wrong.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes,
and the thing that you need to know is it's okay.
It's okay not to know everything.
It's perfectly normal to be in a leadership position and not know everything in
the world.
You don't have to know everything about this particular
job that you're going into or what you don't need to know.
Everything you don't need to,
which you need to do is go in,
ask questions,
listen to people in and say,
anal,
I have done this procedure before.
I've never,
I never worked with this piece of equipment for,
can you show up?
Can you walk me through it?
Can you show me how to do it?
I just want to make sure I understand what you're doing.
Make sure I get it.
Oh,
okay.
Now it's not an excuse to not know anything because if you're in a leadership
position,
you should be studying and reading and learning about whatever the role you're
in is that you can understand it all.
Study the manuals and the regulations and the procedures,
and I'm not saying to follow all those things blindly without common sense.
No,
that's not what I'm saying,
but there's a knowledge base that you should,
you should acquire very quickly when you roll into a leadership position.
So put the work in and then apply common sense,
but this is the same thing that I say every time somebody asks me about how do
you lead this or how do you lead that?
Or how do you lead New People?
Or how do you lead senior people?
It's the same answer every time.
Be Humble.
Listen to them beyond time.
Work hard,
treat people with respect,
way the decisions.
Carefully talk to people and then make a good decision.
Empower your folks to lead.
Don't micromanage them,
but give them at the same time clear guidance about what the expectations are.
It's just leadership.
And when you're a new leader,
it's all good.
You don't need to know everything.
You're not expected to know everything and showing that you could admit that you
don't know everything isn't going to hurt your reputation.
It's actually gonna help you reputation.
Some go in,
be humble,
ask some good questions,
learn as fast as you can,
and it's okay.
And you know,
I was thinking about this,
um,
in the 80s,
and perhaps even in the 90s when guys were losing their hair and going bald,
right?
They do a comb over,
so they'd try and pull their hair over there,
balding scalp.
So it did look like they were going bald.
Right,
right.
And I'm telling you as a leader,
don't do a leadership comb-over do what guys do now,
which is they just shaved their head.
Right.
Okay,
good.
You know what?
I'm going a little fed up top.
All good.
Just going to shave it off.
Hey,
I'm your new leader.
Don't know everything.
It's all good.
Here's where,
here's where I'm weak.
Give me a hand.
Yeah,
no big deal.
That's a good analogy,
by the way.
I don't do the leadership over,
go over.
Um,
what,
tell me if you would agree with this,
generally speaking.
Um,
you've watched some movie demolition man with the bus alone,
Wesley Snipes.
Negative.
Anyway,
Dennis,
he's name is Denis leary.
It doesn't seem like you're kind of movie,
but maybe it would be,
I don't know.
Anyway,
Denis leary,
he's this kind of
underground rebel because basically La is a long explanation,
but I'm making sure I don't eat shit.
It has to do with leadership though for,
okay,
I'm ready.
So mobile leadership,
basically the,
the,
you know,
it's in the future,
whatever.
And um,
the,
the world is turning into this like over sensitized.
Like you can't swear,
he can't eat junk food.
It's the law.
Like,
you know,
so everyone's all nice and real weak and stuff like that.
But there was a group of people who rebelled against it,
went underground,
right.
And the leader of those guys is called egg Edgar friendly.
Right.
And so they go down and he's regarded as his huge criminal.
So the demolition comes back the long story about him.
But anyway,
he's back to help rid the world of these criminals.
So he goes in,
he encounters Edgar friendly and they're not rebel.
They're not these evil people.
They're just like,
just trying to live basically a freedom of free life,
you know?
And they're like,
oh,
he's like,
Hey,
well why don't you lead these people out of here?
Right?
And he's like,
I'm the leader.
Sometimes I do some shit and people come with me.
Right.
That's kind of what he says.
So isn't this,
so here's the question.
Sorry for long explanation.
How this guy's,
he's kind of like worried about people finding him out that he's not a leader.
Right?
Isn't that like a huge sign of humility that he's like on the inside,
he's not.
I know everything,
you know,
and that's kind of like,
man,
I don't know it all,
you know,
and I'm worried about this.
It's actually a good sign.
You are correct.
It's a good sign when you got someone who's like,
man,
I want to do good.
He wants to do a good job.
He wants,
he wants to do good job.
And he's like worried about it.
So that's,
that is good.
That is a good thing.
Yeah.
It's like his humility.
It's like it's so genuine that that's one of his many worries of being a leader.
You know that it's a good sign.
It's better than someone says,
you know what I'm about to take over as a new leader.
Yeah.
And I'm gonna own this thing.
I'm going to own them and I just,
everything and no one knows anything that I know.
So it's going to,
right.
Yeah.
You don't wanna be that guy.
This next one is sort of a statement and sort of a question wrapped in there.
Somebody's calling from law enforcement and I thought it was pretty informative
statement based on one of the other podcasts that we did and it says this,
I currently work a vice,
but I've had my share of use of force on the job.
I quickly learned that you can't knock everyone out and then applying Jujitsu
will reduce injuries to you and the suspect.
So this is what we talked about last time.
Whereas if I,
if,
if my method of controlling you is to strike you,
I'm going to have to beat you over and over again to get you to submit.
Whereas if I know how to do a chokehold,
boom,
you're good.
Back to the quote,
the choke hold or carotid as we called it,
is still permitted in our force policy,
but only in an immediate defense of life situation.
Basically using a choke hold is considered deadly force and equivalent with
shooting someone.
There was a time when the LAPD saying was when in doubt choke him out in the 80s
during the PCP era officers we're applying the carotid choke on PCP suspects
daily.
During one of those incidents,
uh,
male black died from the choke being improperly applied.
Chief Gates made the mistake of going on national television and saying that
male blacks had a higher chance of dying from the choke due to their physical
make and larger Adam's apple.
Okay.
As you can imagine,
this caused an outrage,
which in turn caused the department to fall to political pressure and make the
carotid choke almost impossible to use.
So when I kind of alluded to this on that last podcast that there's the,
there's exactly what happened.
A guy got choked to death,
there was political pressure.
Chief Gates comes out and says that.
And actually I went,
I went online and researched this a little bit.
He made like every classic mistake you could make on this.
And that's why they outlawed using choke holds.
And,
and actually,
uh,
as I read through it,
they,
a bunch of them kind of how I referred to Rodney King beating and said,
here you had guys just wailing on this,
this individual with,
with bats and sticks and Billy clubs or whatever.
And it didn't stop him.
And they referred to that,
that when they looked at the choke hold being used,
that's one of the major cases that they say,
man,
let us let people use the choke hold so this doesn't happen.
Mm.
Uh,
this guy goes on as a certified our con,
which is our constants for arrest and control.
Our con instructor,
I feel the department taking away our ability to use a rear naked choke has
caused many unnecessary shootings and injuries to suspects.
Okay.
It saddens me to work for a department that is being run like a poor corporation
instead of a police department.
So that's kind of the buildup.
Right.
And that's why I wanted to read it because there was just good information in
there and it,
it is very much in line with what we talked about last time and in police work
and,
and also in,
you know,
uh,
combat situations where you're dealing with non combative people in a hostile
environment.
In other words,
you go into a building to capture a terrorist and there's a,
there's a women in there or there's kids in there,
there's teenagers in there that are not combative,
but they're not compliant either.
So they don't have a gun.
You're not going to shoot him,
but you got to get control of him.
Now it gets into the sort of the leadership question here.
How do I keep morale up and stay motivated when I no faith in
the leaders and when the leadership has turned its back on you time after time,
the morale is at its lowest point,
even lower than post 92 riots.
According to the old timers,
we were trained in the academy to be warriors.
Now the department doesn't allow us to call ourselves warriors only guardians.
This change in mentality will sadly cause only more bad shootings and more
officers getting hurt.
So
that's a,
you know,
obviously tough situation and like I said,
for the Jujitsu versus striking,
I think this is spot on.
The jujitsu in the grappling is,
is a far superior way.
Like I said,
if controlling people than striking is,
that's just a reality.
Now on the leadership front,
that leadership question
for me,
I,
I have my own team,
right?
I got my people,
the people that are around me,
the I'm going to buffer all this bad morale and all this stuff.
I'm going to buffer it away from my team.
I'm going to make their lives good.
That's my goal and I'm going to lead toward what my ideal is,
right?
I'm going to lead toward what my ideal is.
Now,
in order to do that,
well,
you got to play the game so that you can get more influence.
If you don't go play the game,
you say,
Hey,
the the bosses don't know what they're talking about.
Bosses don't know what they're talking about and we need to,
uh,
you got to play the game you so that you can get more influence
and,
and
that means doing what you have to do.
That that means not saying,
Hey,
our morale socks and we don't have good leadership.
No,
it means going,
okay,
we're gonna move.
We're going to move forward.
Here's the goal.
Here's what I think.
Here's what I believe.
Hey,
by the way,
I'm going to run this up the chain of command.
I'm going to gather the data myself.
I'm going to do the research.
I'm going to do the administrative work.
I'm going to study the cases.
I'm going to present them and say,
hey,
here's what's happening.
I'm going to do that from an unemotional situation just from pure logic.
Hey,
we've had this many shootings,
we've had this many incidents,
we've had this many,
we've had this many suspects turn up with
with concussions,
there's only one thing that causes a concussion to a suspect.
It's getting hit in the head.
So if we're having,
you know,
42% concussion rate,
maybe we could drop that down if we use something that doesn't cause concussions
but still gives us control.
You got to,
you got to do that legwork
and make life good for the,
that work for you.
And that's,
that's back deck can be a little bit hard to do,
but it's not that hard.
You know,
they,
your subordinates look at you as the guy.
And so the way you carry yourself on the way you present yourself and the morale
that you have is the morale that they're going to have.
That's what they're going to see as the way it is.
And I've always viewed in a single team that would the seal teams to have
different vibes in them,
good and bad.
Someone have good commands and there's a,
there's a new commanding officer every two years at a seal team.
So you get a new guy that comes in and he might be a lot different than the last
guy.
He might be really good,
he might be really bad.
And you know what?
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter to me in a seal platoon as a platoon commander or even as a
squad commander or even as an e five and a seal platoon,
meaning just one of the sled dogs.
I don't care what the upper chain of command,
because guess what?
We're going to do things right?
We're going to make things happen.
Now we're not gonna disobey what's being told,
but if we're being told something that's wrong,
guess what?
We're going to try and get it.
We're going to run up the chain of command.
We're going to be squared away.
We're going to play the game so that we can make the changes that need to be
made.
Because I care about the teams,
just like this guy cares about the,
the police department wants it to be a great force,
wants it to do the right thing.
And so you got to take that attitude that you control your part of the world.
And the more you improve your part of the world and the more influence you gain,
the more you'll have control over the big picture as well.
There's no company,
no corporation that maintains just superb morale all the time.
It doesn't happen,
you know,
peep every company,
every business,
every unit,
every force,
every team has ups and downs.
And they have leadership that comes in and takes over in that everyone considers
to be bad.
And that's,
that's the way it is.
But you got to own your little piece of the world.
And then as you own your priest of the world,
guess what?
Everyone starts performing well.
And as you perform well,
you gain more clout.
And as you gained more clout,
you can influence real change.
And that's what you're looking to do.
So don't let,
don't let that leadership that bad,
what you consider to be bad leadership.
Just don't let that permeate into your head and your world.
Buffer your people from it,
and then do what you can to build the best team you can get so that you can have
more influence so that you can change that policies and the procedures that you
don't agree with.
It's a long haul.
I know it.
Yeah.
I don't have a miracle solution for you,
man.
It's tough.
But that's,
that's,
that's the world.
That's the world.
Yeah.
Especially when,
when you're dealing with the political elements of it.
And then at the same time you have the public eye on you,
you know?
So
as far as
exposure and stuff like that,
it's the newsman in,
in just,
I think media in general,
it's easy to,
to spread all this negative stuff.
It's easy,
you know?
So it's like one of those jobs were in a big way.
It's,
um,
it only gets attention when something's wrong is going on,
you know?
Yeah.
And I would take advantage of a lot of this negative press because a lot of this
negative press like you like this guy saying,
hey,
we're getting more shootings.
We're getting more beatings.
Well,
why is that?
Let's look at our procedures.
Hey boss,
you know what?
We used to use this choke hold and we had x amount of concussions.
We had x amount of shootings.
You could present the information in a logical way that proves what I know to be
true.
What this guy knows to be true,
what anybody that's ever done this type of work before knows to be true,
right?
That is that there are certain techniques that work better than others,
and a choke hold and a grappling type scenario definitely works better to subdue
somebody then striking them in the head repeatedly until they're knocked
unconscious.
Yeah.
That's just the reality of it.
And no one can argue with that and the only reason that they went against it
just for political pressure.
So how do we,
how do we defeat that?
We gain clout.
We move,
we continue to get influenced.
We grow our power,
we,
we strengthen our allies.
We build a coalition and we go forward.
And we went,
and it might take three years,
it might take three months,
it might take six years.
This guy right here that wrote this might need to be the chief of police himself
before he gets it done.
But he,
that's what he does.
He keep,
keeps on the right path and keeps moving in the right direction and does the
right thing so that he can get advanced.
He doesn't make a bunch of emotional arguments against people that have a bunch
of power and he put himself in a bad seat for them where they're looking at him
like he's a rabble rouser.
No,
not a good thing.
You got to build.
You've got to build the relationships up the chain of command so that you become
respected so that people do listen to you.
That's what you gotta do.
That's how you make it happen.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
And on a,
on a side note that the chokehold,
well,
Jiu Jitsu overall isn't just submission.
Hold that.
That's kind of in my being in one of the great things about Jujitsu.
It's like,
I know it kind of seems that way sometimes if you're not,
if you don't do,
do get through whatever you think,
oh,
this guy knows Jujitsu.
Oh,
he'll choke you up,
he'll break your arm,
you know,
um,
the kind of the glamorous part of it is the submission for sure.
But the every other part of it is control,
controlling the situation all the way down to controlling the other guys.
So when you,
when you consider like just,
just an,
uh,
a concept of risk control in Jujitsu,
when you're rolling us on risk control,
just that alone will help,
will help you in law enforcement.
Just that alone,
let alone the whole of Jujitsu.
Just risk control.
That'll help you alone.
So you don't need to necessarily,
and I'm not saying so the chokehold should remain bad.
I'm not saying that,
I mean for someone to die.
I mean,
I know this guy died,
the chocolate was
applied incorrectly,
so I dunno if he broke his neck or his Adam's apple or something like this.
And by the way,
if he had,
if he was better at Jujitsu,
right,
he would have applied it,
put the guy to sleep and then cuffed him and it all bring good to go.
Which happens all the time in class.
By the way,
in training guys get put to sleep all the time.
I get put to sleep.
I don't even know how many times,
a bunch of time.
For someone to die from a choke,
from a regular normal chocolate,
you got to choke him for a long time where your arms would be so tired just from
choking him after he goes unconscious.
You have to keep choking,
choking him for a long time,
so it takes a lot.
The real,
this is probably what you said,
it probably,
you're crushed her.
A hyoid bone,
I think it's called [inaudible].
It's basically your Adam's apple crushes.
You shut your windpipe and the guy didn't get a tracheotomy in time.
That is very,
very rare if ever in Jujitsu.
Now I've had,
I've,
I've seen it happen.
One time a guy passed out and went to sleep and someone was gay choking him.
And so just kept cranking,
didn't realize that he was out for a couple seconds and it ended,
uh,
hurt him.
So you do have to watch out for it.
But I mean,
that is so rare compared to the amount of times that someone gets hit in the
head and gets brain damage.
I mean,
that just happens all the time.
Yeah.
Holy jokes that you can actually do that does,
does that kind of stuff.
But again,
if you know what you did too,
you know the positions,
you know the moves,
you know this submissions,
if you can do some mission,
you're not panicking yet to feel very comfortable on the ground.
You feel very comfortable engaging in combat.
You feel very comfortable engaging in this struggle.
You know,
you're used to it,
you do it all the time,
so you're not freaking out.
You're not adrenaline just cranking a guy in the head with a Billy club over and
over again.
And what does he do?
He puts his hands up.
Why?
Because he's trying to fight me.
No,
he's just trying to protect his head.
But you think he's trying to fight you and that's why you're hitting him even
harder.
Yeah.
So yeah,
it's uh,
it's definitely a tough situation.
And,
and the way you win on the ground in is what you do too.
And the way you win this leadership situation is also with Jujitsu.
You don't go and bang heads with the chain of command.
That's not how you're going to win this fight.
The way you win this fight is by doing Jujitsu against the leadership.
And you get in with them and you gain their trust and you make them think that
you're the man and your team is awesome.
And all,
by the way,
I know our team is awesome and we're totally agree with this policy and we've
supported only this policy's working great and this other policy,
oh,
you know,
when you've got this one policy or that's not so good,
maybe we could do something to fix that.
Let me do some research.
That's how you win.
You got to play the long game.
It's so funny that that analogy like,
dude,
you get to it because really what did you do to is establishing a good position.
Right?
That was a good position.
Knowing where to be and where not to be.
You know,
where to put your weight or where to put your force and where not to put your
force,
you know?
Yeah.
And the other big pieces that in Jujitsu that I was more referring to,
although those are all correct and you have to those,
but it's also a,
you think I'm going to choke you,
but I'm actually going arm lock.
Right,
right,
right.
That's the setup that you flank people in new tack them indirectly.
Right.
You infiltrate and you,
you do things indirectly instead of going and just fisticuffs banging each other
war of attrition.
Right.
Don't do that.
So true.
Okay.
Yeah.
Leading up the chain of command,
I think that's kind of a new concept.
Not In new ways.
We get,
Oh,
you know,
that's a,
that's a chapter in the book.
Yeah.
Or It's actually a sub chapter in the book,
but it's one that people are always have a hard time getting their head around
because I always said like,
my boss did whatever I want them to do.
Yeah.
If people don't understand that that's the way it is.
When you build trust and you take the time and you build the relationship and
you prove over and over again that you're going to do the right thing and the
right situation,
and that you're going to take accountability and responsibility when something
goes wrong and that you have a good head on your shoulders and that you're not
going to get emotional about things and you do all those things and that you're
driving and supporting the mission,
guess what you're gonna get.
You're gonna get support it.
Yeah.
Which means your boss is going to do what you want him to do.
Meanwhile,
you doing the same thing with down the chain of command,
that down Zach list.
You're doing that same thing.
It's crazy cause he just,
I dunno it today,
it doesn't seem as intuitive.
You know,
easiest excuse that anyone could ever have is,
hey,
you know what?
My boss didn't give me what I needed.
That's why I failed.
Yup.
Hey,
you know what?
Our bosses won't let us use choke holds,
right?
And therefore we can't accomplish our mission as well.
No.
Guess what I'm going to make?
I'm going to,
I'm going to lead up the chain of command and I'm going to get my superiors to
let us do what we need to do to do it effectively.
Because guess what?
The leadership is aligned.
Your leadership is going to be aligned with what you want to do.
Do you think that the leadership of the LAPD wants,
you know,
uh,
Victoria,
suspects at perps to get your brain damage and killed?
No,
they didn't want that.
They want it.
They want them to be arrested properly.
They don't want to have lawsuits,
the whole nine yards.
So if you're presenting something to them that's going to improve them and move
them towards the mission and support the ideals of what they're trying to get
accomplished,
of course you're going to get supported.
Now you're going to get these little political battles,
but those are just part of the challenge.
It's bare just part of making it happen.
That's part of the Jujitsu.
Yeah.
When you run with a guy that don't expect them not to fight back,
fight back.
Exactly right.
Last question,
Jacqueline,
do you think having an aggressive mindset is the same as being a proactive?
So I actually looked up the definition for these two words,
aggressive and proactive.
So proactive is creating or controlling a situation by causing something to
happen rather than responding to it after it has happened
and aggressive is ready or likely to attack or confront.
Yeah.
Characterized by or resulting from aggression.
So you can see that the,
the meanings,
there's certainly the similar and I definitely think you have to be proactive in
the world.
You know,
you want to be you and be dictating what happens,
not responding to it.
And
yeah,
that means creating or controlling a situation as much as you can.
Right.
So that's,
that's proactive,
but being aggressive,
that means you're ready to attack.
Yeah.
Is it?
As I always point out,
that doesn't mean that you walk around with your chest puffed out,
ready to bang heads with everyone around you.
It doesn't mean you confront people all the time physically or mentally head on
without a tactically superior plan.
It doesn't mean you go straight forward into conflict without fought and without
reason.
Doesn't mean you engage in attrition warfare.
No,
that is almost never smart.
But what it does mean,
what aggression does mean
is that you're going to get after it.
You're going to move fast,
you're going to think fast.
You're going to out thinking out,
maneuver the enemy.
If I think the enemy is going to attack me,
I'm gonna attack him first.
If I think the enemy's gonna seize a piece of terrain,
I'm going to be there waiting for him,
and if the enemy's going to try and flank me too late,
I'm already going to be flanking him.
So I don't view aggression
as an outward attitude,
okay?
I view aggression as an internal character trait.
A fire in your mind that says,
I am going to win.
I'm going to fight and I'm going to battle and I'm going to use every tool I
have to crush my enemy.
And that tool,
it might be fists,
but it also might be guile.
It could be a frontal attack,
but it also might be a covert assassination.
And it could be a vulgar display of power,
but just as likely
it could be a subtle political maneuver.
That's what aggression is to me.
The on the spot bubble fighting spirit,
the drive,
the burning desire to achieve mission success using every possible tool,
every asset,
and every strategy and tactic to bring about victory.
To me,
aggression is the will to win.
And if that kind of internal and relentless aggression
is your deep fault mode,
then you will win.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So
it's all you troopers out there.
Thanks for joining us in this conversation.
Thanks for listening.
And subscribing end.
If you like it,
go through a little review on iTunes or posted on your social media
so you do what you can to spread the word so we can get more people out of the
darkness.
Yeah.
And into the light.
Thanks for connecting with us through the interwebs.
And if you don't know on Twitter,
I'm at Jocko Willink and echo is at Echo Charles.
Yeah.
Give us a shout out there or ask us any questions you might have and of course
thanks to the companies that support us
and please support the companies that support us.
How can they do that echo?
It's true.
I'm actually back to the Twitter thing.
I that's your surprisingly
in like easy to talk to on Twitter,
you know,
so I know like a lot of people,
there'll be like maybe a follow up question to some questions on here or
something that they've heard,
something that won't require a big long extended answer.
And um,
that's,
uh,
I think from what I've seen and what I've experienced,
that's a good place to ask.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
If you've got a question to ask on Twitter,
I might just respond and say,
no,
I would never do that.
Right.
Or,
yes,
that's an excellent idea,
or whatever.
Or I might say,
Hey,
I'm just gonna answer that in a podcast.
Yeah.
That it's a good spot though.
I think it's not one of these things where you'll just be like,
hey Jocko this and then it goes ignored.
I mean how long I'll be able to keep this up for,
I mean there's starting to be a lot of people on there which is awesome,
but I definitely will like anybody that puts something pertinent.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Somebody is taking some time to talk to me.
I'm going to take some time to talk to him back.
Yeah,
that's good man.
I tried to do the same thing even though people are more just making jokes to
me,
which actually I'd prefer cause my answers there may or may not be reliable.
We'll just say that,
but if you want to support the podcast in other ways of course,
and you want to get some solid supplements,
the only supplement that you take,
right?
Yes.
India actually.
Yeah,
me too.
Aside from like weird preworkout that is sometimes they can only supplement.
They take us from audit quality is guaranteed.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko get a warrior.
Bart,
do yourself that favor.
I would say shroom tech now for Britain,
but the worry bar,
that might be the new stuff,
you know.
Anyway,
do that or go to Amazon or before you go to Amazon,
go to Jocko podcast.com or Jocko store.com and click through the link that you
can support.
That way it's pretty cool.
Kind of passively support with one click.
Boom.
That's all you gotta do or get a shirt while you're on there.
Jocko.
store.com if you like them,
you don't have to put it.
Yeah,
if you like them.
Good.
I do that.
Can we go bumper stickers and mugs to now,
by the way,
Keith,
you didn't know that chocolate has one on his Korean most outlandish uh,
product that we can make.
We'll have to figure that out.
What's the most outlandish Jocko product that we could come up with?
Hit us up on Twitter.
No,
what outlandish product you on an echo.
Create this big old mirror and that create it.
Yeah.
I'm going to create it.
And I think I will also,
if you want to read about these principles,
if you want to read about them,
these principles in a more official manner,
you can check out the book extreme ownership that Leif Babin and I wrote
hardcover kindle audio book.
The audio book is read by myself and life.
So you can,
uh,
you can hear us talk more.
And then finally,
and most important,
thanks to everybody for getting aggressive as you attack your weaknesses and you
make yourself better,
faster,
stronger,
smarter,
healthier.
And of course,
thanks to everyone out there for setting that alarm clock,
opening your eyes,
springing out of bed
and getting after it.
And until next time,
this is Jocko and echo out.